Oh righty Jane,
what's happening?
I'm here.
You are here.
You made it.
And I'm excited too.
Thanks for doing this.
Appreciate it.
So your story is a very fascinating story.
You got a brain injury and you decided
to make a game to help your brain
recover.
Now,
what led you to even
attempt something like that?
I've never heard of anything
like that in the past.
Well,
I had been designing games professionally
and researching them for 10 years.
By the time I hit my head and
it was not my first instinct.
Oh,
I have a brain injury.
Let me make a game.
But you know,
about a month into the recovery,
I wasn't getting any better.
I was really depressed and anxious.
Uh,
I mean I was,
it was like the lowest point of my life.
And I knew from my research
that when we play games,
you know,
we have more optimism,
we're more determined.
We're better able to ask people for help,
right to team up with us,
be your allies.
And I just figured,
well,
uh,
this is like the worst
I've ever felt in my life.
Maybe if I can bring some of that
game full spirit to recovery,
I could kind of jump start
my brain back into healing.
So what was the nature of your injury?
Uh,
I mean it was,
it started out as just
a normal concussion.
And,
uh,
so this is my public service announcement,
right?
Of the episode.
I was standing up from underneath
and open cabinet and I'm a runner,
so I've really strong legs and I was just
in a hurry and I've just full us right
up into the corner of the cabinet,
um,
hit my head.
And it was like classic,
you know,
my husband was joking around,
who's the president?
And I couldn't remember who the
president was and I was like,
Oh shit,
that really bad.
All I could get hit in the head.
You couldn't remember.
This is Barack Obama.
It was,
and all I could remember was,
it's not George Bush anymore,
but I couldn't remember who it was.
Wow.
So just standing up and hitting
the edge of the cabinet.
It was an,
uh,
an opening.
It was an omen cabinet.
So this is the PSA is,
you know,
shut cabinet doors because apparently I
have now learned after this happened to
me that this happens to a lot of people
and you can get a serious head injury as
like a football player by doing this.
So out.
Wow.
So just standing up.
So he stood up quick,
Bam.
Yeah.
Whacked your head.
Did you go unconscious or
did not go on conscious,
you know,
saw stars and everything,
but you know,
a lot of concussions,
it takes a few hours,
the brain starts to swell and it's not
till later that day that you really start
to feel like something's really wrong.
So,
um,
is that what happened to you?
Yes.
Yeah.
Um,
and you know,
it was,
there was no internal
bleeding or anything.
Um,
and so,
you know,
the doctor said,
oh,
you'll be fine and you know,
give it a week,
maybe a couple of weeks.
I come back after month,
they tell me,
Oh,
you know,
some people,
if it doesn't heal in the first month,
it takes three months.
And if it doesn't heal in three months,
it might be a year.
And if it's not a year,
maybe you're stuck like this.
Were you experiencing
the classic symptoms?
Like you couldn't like stare at the sun,
the sunlight would bother your eyes.
Loud noises.
Oh,
I mean,
all light.
Like if I,
I,
I would try to go into like a whole foods
or fluorescent lights would feel like
I was like under fire from weapons.
I mean,
I couldn't,
I was,
I was in bed basically for three months.
Everything,
like all stimulus would
make me nauseous and um,
migraines and everything.
So it was,
it's so it started out normal concussion,
but then it's kind of unraveled into
what they call post concussion syndrome,
which is,
um,
which is a thing that
I didn't know existed,
but a lot of people and the
concussions take up to a year to heal.
Yeah,
they can.
Well,
I,
uh,
from working for the UFC,
I've seen people that neglect those.
Yes.
And it,
it gets really ugly.
Yeah.
I've also seen people
that were great fighters.
There's a guy named Tj grant who
was in line for a UFC title shot,
uh,
got a concussion.
I'm not even from getting
kicked or punched,
it was from,
uh,
grappling exchange,
just bonked his head on something.
I've a,
I believe it was somebody's knee or
someone's hip or something like that and
then was never the same again
and has never fall again.
And it's been like,
I think almost two years.
Yeah.
And I mean that's something I've gotten
actually pretty active in the research
community and trying to share information.
So it turns out like the
first week of recovery,
uh,
can really determine if you're
going to go into this extended,
you know,
it's going to take you three months,
six months,
a year,
um,
if you're not,
if you're not resting enough in that,
that first week.
So the first week it's critical
that you just do nothing.
I mean,
they call it cognitive rest and basically
you want to not do anything that is,
that feels difficult for you.
And so for me,
I couldn't read,
I could only watch TV shows I'd already
seen before because having to process
plot Gnuplot was not,
uh,
was not helpful.
So I was walking like rewatching Buffy
the vampire slayer because I seen them
all like a million times.
Um,
and so,
and yet,
you know,
keep the lights off if they,
keep sunglasses on indoors.
Um,
but the first 48 hours
and then after that,
the first week,
uh,
if you can avoid over
stressing your brain,
you have a much better chance to recover
within the one to two week period as
well as people.
Yeah.
And people don't know
people like they tried to,
I tried to go right back to work.
I was in the middle of writing my first
book and it was due in a couple months.
I'm like,
I can't miss my deadline.
I've got to do this.
I've gotta power through.
I'm going to can barely unlike,
can't even see the screen.
But you're,
when you're,
you know,
when you have a concussion,
you're not thinking clearly,
you are not irrational person.
You're just,
you're just like,
I have to do this.
I have to try.
And other people will
look at you and be like,
what's wrong with you?
You are,
you know,
totally out of it.
Why are you trying to work?
But you're not,
you don't have that same kind of
rational decision making ability.
So sometimes,
you know,
a friend or a loved one needs
to take you aside and say,
I'm not letting you do
anything for this first week.
You've just got to let your brain,
yeah,
and this is correct me if I'm wrong,
but it's relatively new,
our understanding of what takes place
after concussion and what you have to do
to recover.
Yeah,
no,
there's just last year it was a big study
that came out showing that four months
after concussion,
your,
your brain is still different.
There's still,
uh,
it's like a kind of a
scarring that happens.
I get scab,
um,
that certain parts of the
brain will still be thickened,
um,
four months after,
even if you think you're feeling fine,
which means that you're still vulnerable.
You know,
if you were to get hit again,
it would be more dangerous.
And,
um,
and if you're still feeling
symptoms after four months,
you know,
that's why it's like when you cut
yourself open and you get the Scab,
uh,
you can't be picking at the scab by
doing things that are triggering your
symptoms.
Yeah.
Wow.
So who was it that told
you you got to settle down?
Well,
my,
you know,
my doctor had said that,
and of course I'm a,
I mean I'm a science geek that's,
I have a phd.
It's like my background.
Um,
and I was having my husband Google do
Google scholar searches for traumatic
brain injury research cause I
couldn't use the computer just like,
you got to figure,
is this normal?
I'm like,
I started feeling suicidal.
That was,
uh,
that was new for me.
And I'm like literally having
him Google suicidal thoughts,
concussion because I'm like,
is this,
am I really suicidal?
Like,
am I rationally thinking I'm
never going to able to work again.
My husband's got to take care of me.
I should just end it.
Which is what I was looking like.
The voices in my head were saying,
but it didn't feel,
you know,
it's,
that didn't feel like myself.
And so fortunately he was
finding articles like,
wait,
one in three people with a concussion
have suicidal thoughts and that is
actually a reaction to the neurochemistry.
Um,
when you have a concussion,
you don't have dopamine
in the reward pathway,
reward pathways,
which means your brain can't
anticipate anything good in the future.
You become like completely unable
to imagine that you'll feel better,
that good things will happen for you.
And that's just like a perfect
neurochemical foundation for suicide.
So you were able to remember how you
used to think and so you knew this is not
the way I think.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean it was,
I had,
I had like a,
I was able to distance myself a
little bit from the thoughts where,
you know,
I would,
I,
you know,
cause I was just at home,
I wasn't going anywhere.
I would say to my husband,
like,
I feel like I have this
voice that's saying,
you know,
you should kill yourself.
And I would,
I would talk about it because I didn't,
it,
I mean,
I think if you talk about it,
it,
it becomes less,
you know,
this feeling that you have that
you have to really believe and,
and more like the thing that you
can look at and try to figure out.
And um,
and uh,
and so it was like,
it just felt so weird
to me because I'm like,
why?
I don't know.
I had never,
I never had that before.
Um,
and once I knew that it was a
symptom of concussion rather than,
oh,
Jane has figured out that her life is
terrible and logically she wants to kill
herself,
I was able to live with it.
And you know,
the research literature says
they go away as the brain heals.
So I just thought,
okay,
and you know,
it might still,
I might still hear that voice for,
you know,
a few weeks or a few months,
but I know that that's a symptom of
healing and not have actually feel.
So I'm just going to get on with it.
Now.
Is there a medication that you
can take while this was going on?
Anything that speeds up the healing
or anti inflammation medication?
Yeah.
Right.
So this is,
this is what's so hard about
post concussion syndrome
is there's nothing that's
been shown to speed it up.
I mean,
I was offered really
powerful anti anxiety meds,
depression meds.
Um,
I chose not to take them because I
just didn't want to go down that road.
I'd never taken them before.
Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
and there's no known therapies.
People have tried to do like oxygen deep
oxygen therapy and hypobaric chamber.
Yes.
Yeah.
Um,
did you try any of that?
I did not try that.
Um,
but,
uh,
oh,
actually this is a sort
of very exciting for me.
Um,
I,
because there's no good
treatment for this.
When my game worked so well for me and
I saw other people started using it at
work,
well for them,
we were able to get a grant from the
NIH to test this with young athletes,
um,
through Ohio State University
Medical Research Center.
We just released our findings last
week that the game that I invented did
improve the post concussion syndromes
and 100% of the people who used it,
uh,
compared to only 50% of
people who didn't play.
So this is one of,
I mean,
this is one of the first
validated treatments that can,
you know,
reduce the headaches and the
nausea and the confusion and the,
you know,
difficulty.
So how did you get to the point where
you wanted to experiment with a game?
Your,
you're recovering slowly.
Like,
I mean,
how slow is this taking?
Like how many months afterwards?
We still come.
Yeah,
well,
it's 34 days,
which I will,
I will never,
I don't like it.
It was,
it's emblazoned into my memory
34 days after I hit my head,
um,
that I was,
I'm always completely desperate.
I literally was saying to myself,
I'm going to kill myself or I'm going
to turn this into a game because
I mean,
those two options,
it's so strange.
I know,
but so maybe be the only person in human
history that's ever said that I'm going
to kill myself or I'm going
to turn this into a game.
Yes,
yes.
Well,
you know,
I love writing my first book,
which was all about the
psychology of games.
And I just thought to myself,
I should,
I got to prove it.
You know,
I,
I'm writing this book saying that playing
games makes us happier and stronger
and more resilient.
I got to prove this theory.
I mean,
there's all other kinds
of proof in the book,
but I'm like,
I'm going to live it.
Um,
and,
and that was just,
I just,
I didn't know how else to
provoke the positive emotions.
And when we play games and his whole list
of positive emotions that we feel when
we play games like curiosity and
excitement and awe and wonder and pride,
and it's just like,
I gotta get some of these emotions because
my doctor had said the more depressed
and anxious you are,
that can actually slow
down the healing process.
It is actually a detrimental,
right if you,
if you fuel,
if you can feed the freshman anxiety
detrimental in,
in terms of measurable effects
or detrimental in terms
of the way you feel like
that,
uh,
from,
the brain's ability to
heal the neurochemistry of
depression is not conducive to
that.
So literally being depressed can slow
down the physical healing of the brain
itself.
Yes.
And so they're like,
you know,
so try not to worry.
And I'm like,
well,
Geez,
I know.
I was like,
I can't get out of bed.
My books do.
I can't write.
My husband had lost his job a
few months earlier and I'm like,
I may never work and I'm going
to be like a Barista now.
This is like maybe if I can stand,
you know?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so the 34 days,
yeah.
What is the 34 days were
when it was at its worst,
is that right?
I just,
I mean,
it just,
everyone kept saying,
oh,
you'll be fine in a few days.
So we find a few weeks and then I
went and saw my doctor after 30 days.
And then the doctor said,
uh Oh yeah.
By the way,
some people don't get better in a month.
Those people,
it often takes three months.
And uh,
for people who don't get better in
three months and it often takes a year,
and if you're not better than a year,
then you might be like this forever.
And I was like,
oh my God.
It just,
it made me,
it kind of freaked me out.
So did you experiment with
things during this time?
Like w w when you were researching?
I mean,
the only thing that I really experiment
with was a tiny eat things with,
uh,
like Omega is the Omega three,
Omega six,
which are supposed to be good for,
for brain healing.
And there is some scientific
literature on that where,
I mean doctors will say,
eat walnuts,
you know,
donuts.
Yeah.
Cause that's a good like,
uh,
it's,
it's available to them off real good.
It's,
I mean,
I suppose if it can be a capsule,
you can absorb things better from food.
What does walnut wallets,
it's like omega three omega
six fatty acids in fish oil.
Uh,
I'm one of those weird vegans.
Oh,
how dare you.
What about a hemp oil?
Does that have yeah,
hemp is good.
Hemp is really good too.
Yeah.
But at the time,
I don't know,
the only thing I could kind of
get it together to do was walnuts.
Hmm.
Okay.
So walnuts where it,
yeah.
[inaudible] is uh,
oh wife.
What do I do that well
is a football player.
It was a famous football player and he
suffered a lot of concussions and created
something called neuro one.
And uh,
it's uh,
a nootropic blend and he created it to
deal with some of the symptoms that he
had had or some of the repercussions
from all the head trauma that he had a,
so I was wondering if
you'd ever tried anything.
I have not.
I know there are a lot of that sort
of nutraceutical like interest in
experimenting with that.
I did not try that
because of the dopamine.
I was wondering like Serotonin,
like five HTP is really good for,
yeah.
Rebuilding Serotonin or
building blocks with Sarah.
Yeah.
I didn't get it together
to try any of that.
So you were just really struggling.
I was struggling.
I mean,
I would,
I would like,
I would sit on the bathroom
floor and like cry for hours,
but quietly.
Oh.
Like I didn't want my husband,
different Gal.
Nice,
very polite.
And your depression,
it seems counter intuitive to someone
who doesn't know anything like me that
you're saying that you could only watch
like Buffy the vampire slayer because
he'd already seen it before,
but playing your game
like decent part of yeah.
So stimulating,
right?
No,
and actually I couldn't play video games.
I would try to play like peggle I was,
I was like,
Tayga will be easy.
It's like a,
it's like a kind of pinball game,
uh,
where you shoot little pinballs
around pop pigs and it's a,
and they played like
the Hallelujah chorus,
every level you complete.
So I was like,
Yay,
and I'm successful.
They're like playing a prayed for me.
Uh,
I'm like,
that'll,
that'll really help.
Help me.
Um,
but even that was too stimulating.
so I couldn't play video games.
So the game,
I meant it was not a video game.
I mean,
we did eventually make an APP and
a web version so people could,
could,
other people could play,
but it was more like just a set
of rules that I would follow.
Um,
you know,
like you wouldn't like,
oh,
how do you play hide and seek
or how do you play poker?
Just like learn the rules and play.
Uh,
so I just started making up rules for
myself about doing things that you would
do in a video game,
like collecting power ups or spotting
like making lists of the bad guys and all
the ways like where they would show up
and what my strategies were for fighting
them.
And um,
coming up with a quest list.
So like,
what's something I can do in the
next 24 hours to feel better,
like something concrete
that I can accomplish.
And so just starting to
approach my recovery with
these really concrete gameful
strategies.
Um,
and really the,
the,
you know,
the first thing I did was I
adopted the secret identity.
Like my avatar.
I was going to have an Avatar in my
recovery and that was Jane the concussion
slayer.
Because I'm like,
oh,
I'm going to be like Buffy.
And Buffy did not choose to be the slayer.
Right?
Like they just hold her.
You're this layer,
you have to save the world.
And I'm like,
I did not choose to hit my head,
so I'm going to be like her
and just arise to the occasion.
Um,
and kind of try to tap into my inner
sense of determination and being a Badass.
And so what did you do like after you
took on this persona or adopted the idea
of this Avatar?
Like what did you do?
Like what were your power ups?
Like who are the bad guys?
Like,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
and bad guys wear anything
that would trigger my symptoms.
Um,
so,
you know,
bright lights,
a crowded space,
um,
you know,
conversation,
I mean everything.
Um,
but the thing with,
with bad guys and like,
you know,
in a video game like,
oh,
there is,
there's a monster,
you don't run away.
You got to figure out how you're
going to tackle it or get past it.
So,
and the same is true with recovery
from any kind of injury or illness.
You have to keep testing the limits,
right?
Cause otherwise you wind
up never getting better.
You kind of convinced that you're
just flat on your back forever.
And this is sort of an aside,
but as I was doing all the
research for this new book,
I found out that the number one predictor
of disability after a back injury is
avoiding things that make your
back hurt early on during recovery.
So you would think like,
oh,
you have to,
you know,
don't,
don't do anything that
will make your back worse.
But the longer you keep that mindset,
that's a number one predictor of
who becomes chronically disabled.
You're not able to work,
are there,
their life is affected in
a major way and it's not,
the severity of the injury is
not the severity of the pain.
Um,
and so with all kinds of
injury and illness now,
because you get stuck in that pattern,
you never really thinking
yourself as injured.
Yes.
Yeah.
And uh,
so you know,
it's like,
but with all of these things,
it's a careful balance.
So you have to recognize
that the bad guys are bad.
I can't,
I can't go out and be in a
crowded space for three hours.
It can't go to like a lady Gaga concert,
which I really wanted to do.
I'm like,
[inaudible] not going to do that.
Uh,
I said that it's kind of like a,
I'm like the next time she
comes through that'll be like,
what am I epic wins when I can go see her.
Um,
but like you can do little things to task.
Let me go into the whole foods and see
how many minutes I can make it before the
symptoms come back.
So you kind of like testing,
oh,
today was 30 seconds,
I got to leave.
Maybe next week it'll be five minutes.
And then you kind of start to get your
life back because you don't want to get
on that course towards seeing yourself
as is kind of chronically disabled.
So,
so that's,
you know,
you come up with these ways to,
to battle the bad guys,
you know,
every day.
And in the version that
we tested with the NIH,
that's the game is activate
three power ups a day.
So for me that might have been eating
walnuts or like cuddling my dog,
cause that made me feel
like safe and happy.
So anything that provokes
a positive emotion,
if you're depressed and you have to really
find what are the things that can get
through that depression and,
and still make you feel good.
So,
you know,
cuddle my dog,
I'd eat walnuts.
Do you do three of those a day?
One bad guy battle a day where he
really test the limits to see if you're
getting better.
Um,
and one quest today,
which is the smallest possible thing you
can do that we'll kind of move you in
the direction of your goal or recovery
or just feel like something productive
that you want to do.
So I remember one time I,
my quest,
I decided to bake cookies for the Baristas
at the coffee place down this area
is,
I'm like,
I,
I cause I could felt like I
couldn't do anything for myself.
So I'm like,
I'm going to bake cookies
for someone else today.
And,
uh,
as a result randomly I want of getting
free coffee for a year because they were
like,
I cannot believe somebody came like down
with this giant plate of cookies fresh
out of the oven.
Um,
but I did not,
I did not expect that.
Um,
but that was just like,
you know,
find one thing I can do today
that will have a positive impact.
Um,
and that's,
that's the sort of,
there's other stuff you know,
in the game,
but that's sort of the main,
you're,
you're basically using game gain models
to kind of structure your life to make
sure that you're staying engaged,
not hiding,
you know,
actually making progress
to getting better.
This sounds really difficult.
More difficult than I think most people
would ever imagine recovering from a
concussion would be.
I think most people would think that.
I wouldn't,
don't want to say most people,
let me just say what I would think.
I haven't had a concussion,
I don't think since I was probably 20.
And I would think that what it
would be like would be like,
ah,
man,
it feels like shit.
Let me just lie down here.
I'll put ice on my head,
I'll watch TV or something
and I'll just go to,
I'll take a lot of naps,
right?
Like you think it'll feel like a
hangover or something like that.
The problem is that your
thinking becomes muddled too.
So it's not just that you
have these physical symptoms,
you're not able to think clearly.
You're not thinking like yourself.
And that can really lead
to a lot of confusion,
bad decisions.
You know,
people,
uh,
they,
they try to hide the severity of the
symptoms because they think that,
uh,
it will,
you know,
other people will judge
them or they're like,
there's a lot of it that's very common.
I've now learned with concussions.
People hide the severity of
symptoms because there's like,
you just,
you're,
you're not thinking clearly and you think
it's important that other people not
really see.
Um,
but I've,
I've of become this sort of weird
spokes person slash guru for concussions
because of my ted talk about it.
So every day,
literally I hear on Facebook or
Twitter from someone who's like,
just been concussed and they're like,
what do I do?
Um,
and I actually,
uh,
I mean,
I,
you know,
I feel like,
okay,
I'm your ally.
And I'm like always,
you know,
sending direct messages
to like random people.
I don't know,
checking in on them to see I'm feeling
great thing because it's not even like if
your friends or family
will not understand,
they will think,
oh,
you'll be out on the couch for three
days and they expect you to be back to
normal.
And they don't understand
why three months,
four months later,
you're still struggling.
It's not,
I mean,
it has not been discussed enough,
although I think that's changing now.
People,
especially with so many soldiers
coming back with longterm,
uh,
symptoms of,
of the concussions.
No.
The other thing that's confusing to
me with this is that in the beginning,
the first stage of your concussion,
it's critical.
You do nothing.
Right?
But then after a while
you're like pushing it.
Like,
how,
how much time can I spend
at whole foods for free?
Go,
right.
Yeah.
Like many people would think that
that's sort of counter intuitive.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
in the is when the brain
needs the most resources,
right?
So you don't mind early stages like,
yeah,
how many days?
So depending on the studies you read,
it'll say between 48 hours to one week
is the most crucial stage where you want,
where you want the most cognitive
rest and you want to avoid,
um,
it basically just exhausting
the brain because blood,
anything you do that's
cognitively demanding,
it directs blood flow to
different regions of the brain.
You don't want your brain spending time
trying to figure out your email instead
of,
you know,
because there's only,
there's only so much blood to flow around.
Um,
and you don't,
you don't want it to be spent and,
and,
and try and do an email will require
so much more effort from you than it
normally would.
So it's a sort of like vicious cycle.
Um,
now eventually the brain kind
of gets into this sort of,
I don't know,
spaces where it's like,
okay,
now we're working or you've got your,
you've got kind of your thickened up.
Um,
lesions that's going to take,
you know,
four months to kind of dissolve and,
and,
and be back to normal.
Um,
so you can,
you can test and you can say engage and,
and not being engaged.
We'll feel depression and anxiety.
So partly it's like you're trying to
balance the mental health with the
cognitive health.
I mean you can't,
if you were to do
cognitive rest for a month,
if you like being in solitary confinement
and we know that that has really bad
mental health affects.
Right.
So,
um,
your kind of figuring
this out as you go along,
there's really not a
road map that's set out.
No one's ever done this before and you
just sort of take your game designing
skills and apply what you know about
the positive effects of games and you
experiment on yourself like a Guinea pig.
Yeah,
I was worried that you might be
fucking your brain up or Nah,
I'm like
what could be worse than
what was already happening.
Um,
and I mean,
I'll like literally within 48 hours the,
that fog that like super black,
you know,
you wanted,
I fog was gone and it was,
it none of the symptoms and go
and it was as can cost as I was,
but that,
that feeling of hopelessness
really went away.
And because of the fun of it.
So this is,
this is why I wrote the book because
I didn't really understand why worked.
I knew it worked for me and then I put
the rules online and people started
writing me from all over the
world that they were using it.
And not just for concussions.
I mean,
people were writing for,
you know,
I have cancer,
I just had knee surgery.
Someone you know,
who was just like noticed
with als starts playing it.
And uh,
um,
it,
it seems to be,
it seemed to be extraordinary
effective at treating depression,
anxiety and also making
people feel just stronger,
just like better of themselves.
And I did not understand it.
And this is,
I say this all the time people,
because there can be a lot of skepticism
that a game can be helpful during a
really serious,
uh,
challenge in your life.
It sounds like trivial.
It sounds stupid.
Um,
so I freely acknowledged,
I didn't understand why it worked.
It seemed kind of absurd to me for people
with much more serious problems and I
had to,
um,
so that's why I wrote the book.
It's why I started doing,
in our clinical trial and the studies
we've been doing for the last few years to
try to understand because I didn't at all
I knew was that it seemed to be having
all these positive effects and that,
uh,
that was,
it was,
I mean even to a game designer like
myself who believes in the power of games,
I was really taken off guard.
Right.
So how did you structure it?
Like,
did you first start off just coming up
with things like power pills or walnuts
and bad guys or depression and how did
you like put this whole thing together?
Yeah,
I mean,
I just started making youtube videos,
which is really funny.
You can go back and look at like
the first youtube videos of me.
It's like,
I don't think Scott,
like why I'm making a game for my
concussion or something like that.
And First Youtube video you made,
what were you still suffering?
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
How many months was it into?
I thought this is like,
I think on day 34 this
is like the day I'm like,
I'm making a game.
I'm going to make a youtube
video explaining the game.
What's it like to when
you watch that video now?
Oh,
it's crazy because I can't,
you can see,
I can't think of words.
Aye.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What is it?
What would it be under?
Why I'm making a game?
Concussion,
something like that.
Jamie.
You'll find it.
Yeah.
Cause it's like you can see I can't,
I can't,
I mean,
you see how fast I talk.
Am I right?
I'm like talking.
Really.
So how long ago was this?
Five years ago?
Yeah.
And how long do you think it was
before you felt like 100% you again?
I mean,
so I'm like 99% right now.
Maybe.
Yeah.
I mean there's still not 100%.
No,
there's the,
yeah,
there's still some things
like certain lights.
I can't be around.
Like it's,
it creates,
it's like,
it feels like I'm having five years later.
Yeah.
Well let's,
let's play this real quick.
Okay.
I am making this video to
explain and project some volume.
Jack hijacked a game to help the recovery
process that I'm dealing with it after
I hit my head and got a concussion and
that was about five weeks ago and their
recovery has been very slow and hard.
So,
um,
it's getting to a point where I feel like
I need again to help me get what I was
doing some research today
about post concussion syndrome,
which is what definitely told that
weird artifacts and the sound will
concentrating trouble.
I mean,
I'm probably just sitting
there with my laptop in my lap.
Um,
serious planning,
mental problem solving that would give
me a concussion pickler and having a very
hard time.
I was not a pro.
Um,
and uh,
and I get dizzy a lot.
Um,
and I get headaches and nauseous,
that kind of thing.
It's definitely,
yeah.
Can really see clearly you're,
you're moving way,
way slower.
You're talking way slower.
You can see you're struggling.
No.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Unless you're on meth right now.
I am a naturally very energetic person.
It's fascinating to me
that you're not 100% still.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know it and I'm not sure entirely
why I was knocked out once when I was
younger,
like knocked out for like five minutes.
Um,
what happened?
I fell off a sliding board.
What's a sliding?
I feel like a Philadelphia thing.
I don't know.
Uh,
like a slide like,
uh,
like at the playgrounds
that you go down there.
Oh,
fried chicken Philly.
We called it sliding boards and I fell
right off the side and hit my head on a
cement block.
Oh yeah.
That's what I was really young.
That was my first concussion.
So that's probably
what's going on to,
as it were,
repeated concussions,
right?
No,
no.
What's interesting is I was so young,
I did not,
I was like,
I don't know if it's
like four or something.
I actually didn't know
that I'd had a concussion.
I thought this was my
first concussion in 2009.
And the doctor's like,
oh,
have you had a concussion port?
No.
Um,
because obviously everyone knows
now if you have more than one,
it can start to,
the healing will take longer.
I didn't know until like
a month into my injury,
I'm talking to my parents
and they mentioned,
well,
you know,
the last time you had a concussion you
were feeling better and much faster.
And I'm like,
what?
What,
what last time?
Oh,
you remember when you fell off
the sliding board when you were,
you know,
anything when there were four.
I know,
uh,
my five year old doesn't remember
anything when she was four.
No.
Like,
you know,
when you broke your collarbone,
I'm like,
oh,
I do remember like wearing
a sling for collarbone,
but I didn't know that I had a concussion.
So,
uh,
so even though you were
four and then the next one,
you were an adult.
It's still
maybe,
I mean,
it's,
I,
eh,
people like Reese,
the fines does not quite
understand how this works yet.
Like if,
if the cumulative Knox have to be all
within the same few years or if it can
stretch out over a lifetime.
I try not to think about it
too much because I'm like,
you know,
God,
if it happens again that I'm really,
you know,
but I'm actually,
I like walk around like
this covering yeah,
give,
I'm,
if I'm at like at a,
you know,
like a concert or like in a 200 a element.
I literally want,
if I'm like at a nightclub or something,
I want to wear a helmet.
I'm like wondering if
I can bring that back.
I stayed a girl that
used to go to mosh pits.
It was crazy.
And uh,
she got headbutted by a dude once she
came over to my apartment after she,
uh,
had been marching and she's like
holding her head and I'm like,
what do you deal with?
I think she went to see
some crazy fucking bad,
I'm trying to remember the,
is there a band called the creeps?
It was,
yeah,
it was in Boston and like 88 89.
So we should be wearing helmets.
You definitely don't get
headbutted in a mosh pit.
Yeah.
But I would think like there's certain
assholes like drunken dummies and you'd
go out to places you,
you know,
no.
And I'm short,
so I'm always worried about the elbows.
Someone's like reaching for something,
some big dude.
We'll just,
I mean,
even like on planes when people
are taking down their luggage,
I like cower by the
windows or by the window.
Smart.
Yeah.
That's um,
the,
the recognition of vulnerabilities,
uh,
an issue with people that get hurt because
then all of a sudden you realize you
can get hurt and sometimes you just
walk on eggshells all the time.
It reduces the quality of your life.
Exactly.
And that's,
I mean,
that's sort of,
that gets to that idea of,
you know,
spotting the bag eyes,
things that could hurt you and
then you decide kind of how,
how comfortable you are.
You can't just run away.
You can't just hide.
You have to kind of push your
comfort limits a little bit.
Um,
so I'm not going to go skiing.
I that ski ski.
Yeah.
Wow.
I didn't think certain.
There's certain things now that I feel
like it's not worth the risk to me.
A third,
you know,
I can only imagine.
I just started skiing at 45.
It's my first time skiing.
I fucking wiped out hard last year,
but that's fine.
Just,
and didn't hit my head and
I'm pretty good at falling.
I know how to fall or Tom
molden rolled with it,
but I was like,
dude,
I was going to fast when I wiped.
Oh yeah,
there's a video that's online too.
We retweeted earlier today.
This fucking kid is in Colorado and he's
on a skateboard and he's going 70 miles
an hour down a hill and you just watch it.
And like every part of my
body's like tingling with fear,
you know,
that anticipation injuries.
Just,
you tweeted that.
Did you treat the roof topper?
Like the guy in Russia?
So,
you know,
I'm really interested in like neuro hacks,
how you can do little
things to like change,
like how your brain is working right now.
Um,
and that video,
it seemed to me would be really good
for people to get a little bit of
adrenaline going.
If you're like on your couch and you're
like having a hard time getting yourself
out of bed.
Oh my God,
he's going 70 miles an
hour down this crazy hill
with horrible music and it
looks like a video game.
Right?
I mean,
it's just crazy that this kid is
doing this because you can't stop.
I mean,
actually,
he's really good.
Yeah.
So there's a point where he,
uh,
he turns a skateboard
sideways to slow it down,
like at the very,
uh,
but,
and there's a couple little wiggles there.
It looks like he's about to go down.
And if he goes down,
dude,
you're breaking everything.
Oh yeah.
You're going 70 miles an hour.
I mean,
he is fall lying.
There's no way.
I mean,
they're not faking this unless
this is some sort of advanced CG.
No,
I was going to say,
I mean,
it almost could be a video game.
Like watch when he reaches his hands down,
he has some kind of crazy gloves on
and when he reaches his hands down,
there's certain parts in the video
where he's a touching the sparks,
sparks the sparks.
I look at that.
Jesus fucking Christ,
I cried.
He almost fell.
I mean he's getting like
really close to falling.
Like there's a couple times there where
there's like this intense wiggle and
he's talking himself like a,
a speed skater so that he can go faster.
Yeah.
Crazy fucker.
Like what is wrong with kids?
I mean I get it.
This is an adrenaline rush.
But when you see this knowing what
you suffered from standing up under a
cabinet.
Yeah.
And does this freak?
Does he have a helmet on?
Is that a hat?
That's a helmet.
It's a helmet.
Held him.
Was that how long are going to do well?
Oh little.
We get legal.
You this,
look at that.
That kid is crazy.
That's how he slowed down and now he's up.
He's down to a reasonable pace.
But when you see him,
he'll do it again to slow it down.
He grabs a board and look at this.
That is nuts.
Are you figuring out how many hours have,
I mean cause he's like a virtuoso at.
Yeah.
So there's like thousands
and thousands of hours.
Yeah.
He's put the 10,000 hours in.
But good Lord,
when you see something like that,
no one what you went through,
like anything like when you
see like dirt bike riders
doing fine.
I actually have a really,
I stopped watching professional football,
um,
after I used to,
you know,
I mean go 40 niners right.
But,
uh,
I can't,
I can't watch football anymore.
Like I just,
I mean,
I can,
but,
uh,
I don't enjoy it in
the same way because I,
I just feel,
I feel bad players and when I see,
when I see like a really hard hit,
I just,
I just feel bad.
So
I think that's something a lot of people
are struggling with these days with all
these,
you know,
the real sports story that they did on
traumatic brain injury and the issues
that people are having and the,
all the stuff that I've seen
from fighters over the years is,
it's definitely affected my enjoyment.
What's this retiring after
concussion next hit to my head.
Could possibly,
wow.
I mean,
this is a thing now,
right?
Three,
four,
yeah.
They're,
they're retiring one,
two years into their career.
Yeah.
Well,
there's more of that now than ever before
because guys are realizing first of
all,
at the end of,
uh,
at the end of their career,
they're most likely
going to be debilitated.
Yeah.
I mean,
almost all of the players that take a
lot of hits suffer from serious injuries
for the rest of their lives.
Yeah.
And so when you're young and
you're looking at your future,
go and look,
I could put all my energy
into this and you know,
be a mess.
Or I can say,
you know what,
I'm still young.
I'm 23.
I could do anything I want.
Like,
look,
I've been in the NFL,
I've,
I've experienced it.
Let me just get the fuck out of here.
Yeah.
Go try something else.
She worried that the future
of the sport is going,
there's going to be a
big socioeconomic divide.
We're the only people who,
who really want to play and are willing
to take that risk are people who feel
like they have nothing to lose.
You know,
um,
we just stat and there's the
people that want to watch it.
Like we,
we've experienced that with the UFC too.
There's a,
there's a bunch of people
that want to watch the,
the head injuries that just,
they don't know what they're seeing yet.
They don't understand.
Like when you,
you watch somebody get
kol like really badly,
when you see someone get head kicked or
no dropped in their head or something
like that,
you,
you just see excitement.
He still like,
oh,
that guy just beat that guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I know.
And I,
it's,
uh,
yeah,
I can't watch,
I can't watch fights either for the same
reason when I have friends who are so
into it and,
you know,
you just,
because I mean so,
right.
I Love Games.
I understand a good game.
Good,
good sport is a good game.
Um,
and,
uh,
you admire people's ability
to be so good at this.
You know,
this thing that we've created
to test human potential.
But,
um,
but you know,
if I've sort of started drifting to
sports where there's fewer concussions,
although,
you know,
like I'm a big tennis fan and one of
the big stars just got a concussion this
weekend at the u s open,
so she slipped,
uh,
in the,
in like the locker room after
doing like the ice bath after like,
uh,
um,
and,
uh,
it's interesting they showed her coming
to the courts to see if she could
practice with her sunglasses on the
hoodie pulled up and she just has that,
that look that like now I saw her,
I was like,
oh my God.
I mean,
she's like right in that zone of where
she thinks she's going to play because
she's not thinking clearly,
but you can see her.
I mean,
she's like a shell of herself.
Um,
so when you see something like that,
do you want to reach out?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
No,
I know.
And people have been
tweeting at her to be like,
you have to get super better,
you know,
finish their clinical trial.
You could,
I know,
be better,
but what is super better,
right.
Yeah.
Uh,
I do,
I do want to reach out because,
um,
because I know how hard it was and how,
how so few people,
I mean just the,
the general public conversation about
this is not caught up to kind of the
reality of what people experience
well that uh,
those ice baths,
that's a,
one of the problems with that,
that form of cold therapy is that
you get out in your legs like rubber.
Yes.
You're,
everything's not working so good.
That's why you can't do that
stuff and then work out.
Right.
You know,
to some forms of cold therapy that you
can do and you can work out after it,
but not those ice pass.
I have done,
I run marathons.
I have done some ice bath and I've,
yeah,
I,
have you ever done the
whole body cryotherapy?
We stepped in the chamber and you go
to 250 degrees below zero for three
minutes.
It's awesome.
Oh,
it's the best body element.
Like do you kind of,
is there like a mental
state that is changed?
Oh yeah.
Well,
your brain produces
something called neoprene,
Nefron,
cold shock proteins and
all these different things
happen when you hit minus one
50 degrees below zero.
Yeah.
It's,
there's also the something
that someone just invented,
one of the reserve brought this up,
something called a cryo helmet.
Like you put it on over your head.
It's like a gel pack thing.
Like a,
it's almost like a Hoodie and
you put it on and it's like they,
they really recommend it for
people that have had head injuries,
sort of reduction in swelling.
Right.
I could,
I mean I could see that if you're
trying to treat the inflammation.
Yeah.
Because it's like a whole thing.
Like I got like a frozen helmet,
you know,
he goes a little gel packs.
I took one of those.
But it's a helmet on your head.
I will of course I'm going to say no.
You got to pull up like
Google scholar though.
For me,
I want to see like is there
any literature on this yet?
Um,
cause I'm,
so I'm like hold up.
I don't pull it.
I'm fairly conservative with
telling other people what to do.
Like for myself,
you know,
I was like,
oh,
I'll make a game.
But for telling other people to do,
I'm like,
wait until there's a peer
reviewed paper for sure.
But fighters,
you know,
bas Rutten who's a former
UFC heavyweight champion,
great fighter was talking about that.
That's a,
that's important.
Like when guys get hit to ice
their head after it's over,
and he in his rationale was like,
look,
if you hurt your knee,
what's the first thing they do?
They put ice on it.
Why don't you put ice on your head?
I was like,
that actually makes a lot of sense.
Yeah,
I know,
that's really interesting.
I was just reading about,
you know,
you probably know this,
they say like five minutes
after you stopped breathing,
supposedly you have like brain cell death.
Have you heard this?
If somebody who's drowned and you
can't get them breathing again in five
minutes,
um,
then supposedly it's too late and they're
now finding that if you cool down the
body and the brain that
they can come back.
You can be not breathing,
not,
you know,
heart,
heart beating for more than five minutes.
Now if you get the body
temperature so enough,
pack them with ice.
That's what they're doing now
they're starting to do that.
It's like a first,
uh,
I know,
and I was like,
I was just telling my husband,
I'm like,
we need to,
we need you to read this literature.
So cause I want to know if I'm supposed
to do this or wait until like the EMT
shows how,
like if something happens,
should I start packing ice or,
yeah.
I'm not sure.
Uh,
I'm not actually sure if the
practical implications of this.
As you get older you realize more and
more hell damn vulnerable people are so
physically vulnerable.
Yes.
Well this is really
interesting because you know,
I,
in doing what I do,
I have confronted a lot of
skepticism and I would even say,
I mean people who are
really quite sarcastic,
but they hear about this,
Oh,
I'm going to adopt a secret identity.
It's going to make me not depressed.
You know,
usually it's people not suffering
from depression who say this.
Cause if you're really suffering
from something debilitating,
like clinical depression,
you will try anything.
So the people who are pretty
happy and healthy and they'll,
they'll say this,
it sounds ridiculous.
Um,
but,
but you're talking about bloggers,
right?
Yeah,
it's,
well,
yeah.
And The New Yorker just
ran a big giant piece,
uh,
about,
about super better,
um,
uh,
sort of,
you know,
it was both positive but also like
still this sounds kind of ridiculous.
Well it does sound ridiculous,
but then it's like,
oh,
can work and sound ridiculous.
Exactly.
And that's why it's like,
I,
uh,
when you realize how vulnerable people
are and how much is out of our control,
I mean those are the people who are
the first in line to try this and who
benefit the most.
So we had half a million people
play an electronic version,
like logging their power ups and they're
bad guys and quest so that I could get
data on it and see what are
the most effective power ups.
Like how often do you have to,
you know,
check in to,
to get better.
And we found that people with the,
which is the most painful and difficult
situations where the ones that were
benefiting the most,
it's like sort of the more you
realize how vulnerable you are,
the more open you are and the
more this kind of concrete,
purposeful,
positive action can actually
make a big difference.
That makes sense.
I mean,
once you feel the vulnerability you,
you,
cause it'd be,
it becomes real.
Whereas when you look at someone
who has a broken leg and you go,
oh,
I can intellectually understand
that that person broke their leg,
but I don't know what it feels like.
Right.
You know,
if you've never broken your leg,
you don't know that feeling.
You're like,
ah,
fuck,
I can't even stand on this stupid thing.
Is that,
that feeling where like,
okay,
now what?
What do I have to do?
Tom would have to do,
and then the reality changes.
Yeah.
And the reality of you having that head
trauma and trying to figure out like,
there's gotta be a way
to get out of the swamp,
this mental swamp.
And I'm stuck in a let's
fucking make a game.
Like let's do it.
You like you're just,
I mean,
it makes sense to me.
It be a person has been through a bunch
of surgeries and injuries and stuff.
It totally makes sense to me because
there's a reality that every time I've
really badly injured myself,
like where I needed knee
surgery or something,
there's like a,
just an acceptance just goes,
Huh,
let's just go do it.
Let's go do it because
now this thing's broken.
And until that happens,
there's a bunch of people will tell you,
well,
once you try rehabbing it,
why don't you try doing this?
Like,
no,
it's like,
I don't think you get it.
No.
And a lot of times you'll have an
injury and you won't know if it will get
better.
Um,
W W if you'll be able to get back
to what you were doing before,
which is actually where the name super
better comes from because I wasn't sure I
would ever have the same
cognitive capabilities I had.
And I,
at that time,
I was using,
you know,
I was,
I had just gotten my phd,
I was doing research.
I was,
you know,
I was to being able to have
an intellectual profession.
Um,
and so I,
everyone's like,
get better soon.
And I'm like,
well,
what does that mean?
That means get back to who
you were before this happened.
And I didn't know if I would ever
be able to do any of that again.
So I thought,
well,
I'm not going to get better.
I'm going to get super better.
I'll just be different.
I'll be like this new
super version of myself,
like Spiderman.
Uh,
you know,
he got bit by the radioactive
spider and this concussions,
my radioactive spider,
and I don't know who I'm going to be,
but it'll be someone different.
And,
uh,
and instead of just trying to,
you know,
because anytime you're having
an injury or an illness,
you don't know who you're
going to be at the end of it.
He might be back to normal.
It might be different and you want it to
be the best different that it could be.
Yeah.
There's been many stories of people that
have gotten knocked in the head and all
of a sudden had musical
house mathematical talent.
Yeah.
What are you hoping that that was going to
the weirdest experience?
Um,
so I'm a very introverted
person by nature.
I,
you know,
like if my phone rings,
I won't answer it.
Like even if you're my
friend or like your mind mom,
like,
oh,
it's too much social interaction.
Like I get anxiety,
I can't answer it.
So,
uh,
that's been like my whole life.
But,
um,
we,
what we know about,
like the difference between
introverts and extroverts,
introverts tend to stimulate
themselves with internal thinking.
They're always,
they're always thinking and they don't
need other people to kind of get them
excited.
Extroverts respond much more
positively to external stimulation.
It's like a,
it's like they're just primed.
If they see someone smiling at them,
it's like a cocaine hit,
you know.
So when I had the injury I
couldn't think to myself anymore.
I couldn't like entertain
myself with my own thoughts.
And I became like this super extroverted
person and I started like calling
everybody in my phone,
like contact lists in
which people I would never,
I mean we wouldn't even pick
up the phone and I'm like,
please talk to me cause I couldn't,
I couldn't literally cannot
be an introvert anymore.
But that only lasted for like a couple
months and then my surgeon to get better.
I went back to being
introverted and I still,
today I,
I try to keep some of that
because I actually discovered,
wait,
I,
I really like,
it's nice to talk to people.
He does not actually a burden,
you know,
but,
but that's,
so that was,
that was,
that was one of the sort of super better,
you know,
changes for me is I realize and they were,
we know from psychological literature,
extroverts really are happier.
They live longer,
they're psychologically healthier.
It is,
if you can convince yourself to be social,
it's,
it's really good for you.
Um,
the introverts just so have
a different brain chemistry.
So their brains telling them,
yeah,
two people scary.
Like,
you know,
too much stimulation.
Uh,
yeah.
Well that's the,
one of the weirdest things
about online interaction is it,
it's kind of a combination of both
introvert behavior and extrovert bay.
Cause even though you are
interacting with people,
you're not seeing no,
it's controlled
and that's,
it's,
it's the face to face
can be really a daunting.
Yeah.
Like you'd like the,
just the,
the energy that it takes.
Yeah.
I mean it's not,
it's not the same thing as being,
I mean,
just cause you're introvert
doesn't mean you're,
I dunno,
like socially unable.
Like,
you know,
you're not,
you're not a misfit.
Well,
obviously you,
you're very capable of keeping
a regular conversation going.
Yes.
I mean,
you're done.
Then you can say you're an introvert,
but you're easily,
you know,
you're easy.
You,
you're,
you're like,
you're just talking.
No problems.
You're not,
yeah.
I've had some introverts
on this podcast before,
and then it's obvious.
They're like,
everything's an effort.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's probably more of an
effort for me than it looks.
Hmm.
But I think it's more of an effort
for everybody then it looks,
maybe that's a good point.
Yeah.
I think that I'm just,
one of the issues with online interaction
is that you don't see the people and
you know,
you just,
it's just like,
my intention is it's kind of ambiguous.
You know,
like you're write something or you
put something out there and it's a,
it's not completely clear.
Like if you say something,
I get the tone.
I can tell if you're being sarcastic.
And I,
if,
uh,
if someone,
if you say something mean to me,
like we have to look at each other,
I'm like,
fucking really?
Yeah.
Like in this weird thing to it.
Whereas if you do that online,
there's like none of that.
Yeah.
I think that there's,
there's something very strange that's
going on in our culture right now with so
many people spending a giant amount of
their time only interacting with people
through text.
Absolutely.
Well that's one of the areas of
research that I was diving into.
So,
you know,
cause I don't just know
research brain injury stuff,
I typically research video games and how
they change how we feel and think and
act.
And what does that mean you're punched in?
The field is called performance studies.
So I was just basically
studying how people perform,
um,
in video games and as a
result of video games,
sort of collaboration skills,
they're sort of psychological performance,
um,
things like that.
At,
at Uc Berkeley it was where I studied.
And uh,
so one of the things that we know
that's happening in video games is that
there's a really big difference between
playing a video game in the same room
with somebody and playing online.
And so like if we're playing call of
duty and I'm trying to kill you and if
we're playing in the same room,
we actually undergo really great,
uh,
it was kind of,
they call it synchronization.
So our heart rates,
we'll sync up our breathing rates,
sing GAAP,
we get it's kind of mirror
neuron in process going on
where it's like blood flow
is mirroring where it's flowing.
The patterns of activation are
mirroring each other and all of that is
associated with more compassion,
more empathy.
We like each other more.
We trust each other more,
even if the game is violent,
even if we're competing.
Um,
all of this happens
and it happens because,
you know,
when you were playing a game
with or against someone,
you have to try to get in their brain
like what are they going to do next?
What's next?
Move.
Um,
and so your brain starts to mirror
what you think they're doing.
So it's this,
it's this really intense mind
body mirroring that goes on.
What triggers the mirroring,
the observance of the
character on the screen?
Uh,
well,
no,
it's,
it's because it only works
if you're in the same space,
physical space with them,
but you're still looking at a screen.
Yeah.
Well you're trying to
think what are they doing?
And there just something
about if you're the,
you may think you're
looking at the screen,
but there's also a general awareness,
like when you're sitting next to someone,
right,
you're aware of sort of
what's going on and the,
and cues that you're picking up,
body language cues.
And if you'd like turn to look at them,
you'll even just in a split second,
you'll get this sort of
facial expression queue.
Um,
and that doesn't happen in online games.
so what we've just been measured.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So what we've seen is if you
take the same game and play it,
you know,
against somebody in the room,
you wind up with these positive impacts,
uh,
like,
you know,
more compassion,
more empathy.
You like each other more.
If you play the same game online,
you're not able to see
their facial expression.
You're not able to get the same,
uh,
sinking phenomenon.
You actually dehumanize the opponent,
you,
your testosterone goes up,
you feel less empathy towards them.
Um,
and so it's one of the reasons
why in the book I talk about how,
you know,
unless you're actively trying to change
your personality to be more aggressive
and you want to,
I don't know,
for some reason you feel like you
want to be kind of more of a have,
it's like aggressive,
hostile personality.
A,
you should not spend more than half your
time trying to beat strangers online
because of the,
because it's just not
after times,
a lot of time,
half your half your gaming time.
Oh Jesus Christ.
What are you recommending?
24 hours in a day?
No more than 12 hours.
Killing strangers.
And it actually,
yeah,
21 hours a week is where you start to
see the benefits of games reduce and
negative impacts increase.
So there's another public
service announcement.
Um,
what have you,
have you done it in layers where you know,
you like I used to do a land parties.
My friends used to play quake lan parties.
Um,
and it's really fun.
You know,
there's a lot of camaraderie and stuff.
Yeah.
But if you put a barrier up,
yeah.
But during the same room or if they're
in a room that's right next door,
but you know they're there and may be
can hear their voice or if you shut that
door and you can't hear their voice,
have you changed?
Have they seen like what,
what if the mirroring is consistent?
Yeah.
I'm the studies that I've seen show that
you have to be in physical proximity.
So if there was a barrier
and we were unable,
I was unable to look over and get those
cues from your body language or from
your facial expression
that it would not happen.
How'd your cubicle thing and
I can just like reach up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Then you,
then you probably would,
I like,
I liked this idea of this aging.
The thing I'm really curious about is
with twitch and now youtube gaming is if
you can watch somebody playing and,
and now you're seeing their face,
um,
while they're playing a game.
Um,
studies have shown that watching someone
play a game that you know how to play
will trigger the same mirror neurons
because your brain can kind of emulate,
uh,
if you're playing a game,
I don't know how to play.
I don't know if the controls,
I don't know the goals.
My brain will just be like,
I don't know.
Right.
If I know how to play the game,
like,
oh,
I know what she's trying to do.
I know what a strategist.
Yeah.
Whatever it is,
everybody knows what to do,
can away from the ghost.
Yeah.
So one thing I'm interested in
is if I can see someone's face,
you know,
while they're playing the game,
they're playing a game.
I know,
could you get some of the benefits,
but it would only be uni directional
because if you're like live streaming your
game plan,
you can't see me.
So,
uh,
but it would be interesting since we
know that if you get this mirror neuron a
fact,
um,
it makes people want to help each
other more like each other more.
I'm like thinking like being a powerful,
you know,
twitch streamer or youtube game streamer
like could make you really cultivate a
large community of people
who really want to help you,
which put seems like,
like if I were building an empire
of like a new kind of community,
I feel like that would be what I would
be building because they would be really,
um,
it would be like a really tight bond,
you know?
That's fascinating.
You know,
this twitch thing has caught a lot of
people by surprise because I think a lot,
no one would have ever thought that it
would be so popular to watch someone play
video games.
Right.
And the mirror neuron thing helps explain
it because it's not like watching TV
where it's just passive.
If you know how to play the game,
your brain starts working to sort
of process it and anticipate,
you know,
what they're gonna do next.
Trying to figure out what has,
what decision lawmaker
or where they'll go.
Um,
and so you're actually getting a lot
of the same stimulation as if you were
playing the game yourself.
And that's the thing
people don't understand.
Um,
we see this with musicians too.
If you know how to play a
musical instrument and you
watch somebody playing that
same musical instrument,
your brain starts to,
you know,
activate as if you are
playing it yourself,
which is why it can be
more interesting for,
you know,
somebody knows how to play the piano,
to watch someone else play the piano or
listen to someone else play the piano
versus somebody who doesn't know.
That totally makes sense.
When a,
I used to play quake,
we used to watch these uh,
things.
Uh,
they were,
they call them demos and what it was
was a game that they would record.
Yeah.
And so you'd see it
through a player's eye,
so you get to see how good a player
moves and then it would make you play
better.
You would do,
would play better after you saw that.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
They were really popular.
Like demos were super popular.
You would download them and you would
play them in game like in your game.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
Do you remember that?
I was like into counter
strike a little bit.
Well that's the case with athletics too.
Um,
a lot of people tell me that when they
watch like a really good basketball
player play that it makes
them play better basketball.
Yep.
I know it's the case with pool.
I played pool and when I watch
really good players play,
like I can kind of emulate what they do.
But if I feel like it's
not just like copying,
but I kind of tune in.
Oh yeah,
they're good
because your brain is practicing it.
I,
I find that after a grand slam in tennis,
it was because I'll watch me only reason
why I'm not watching tennis right now
is because we're here doing this.
I like something going on.
I had the u s open,
my favorite player is playing
like literally right now
in your player Joe Willie
Tsonga who I named my puppy after.
I have a dog named the Songa if
he's playing right now to get,
get to the semis.
Um,
but no spoilers because I'm recording it.
but I know that,
so I'll go like two weeks watching
hours and hours of tennis a day.
Then I go to play tennis and I'm better.
I'm absolutely,
I,
I see the ball better,
I get to it better.
Um,
I'm absolutely,
She,
because my brain has spent two
weeks mirroring everything.
I see.
But if you don't know how to play,
if you've never played,
your body won't do it.
So you have to have,
you have to have a model for,
for this to work.
Totally makes sense.
Yeah.
Because like something like tennis,
like I've maybe played once in my whole
life when I was in my early twenties,
so you wouldn't get as much benefit.
I wouldn't get anything because
I'm not going to play again.
I don't think.
I just don't have time in the day.
But I,
I totally understand that.
That totally makes sense.
I think that probably is the case with
pretty much everything that people do.
It's one of the reasons why,
uh,
a sense of community amongst people that
are all involved in the same sort of
endeavor.
So important because you kind of push
each other and inspire each other and also
you kind of feed off of each other.
Maybe one,
like if we were all comedians,
maybe you would have like a certain kind
of style that I don't have and I would
see your style go,
oh,
Jane's got this crazy
thing she's doing well,
that's Kinda cool.
And then like maybe I would do something
that you didn't do and you're like,
maybe I need to like be more this or me
more and sort of tune into how people
are doing to the point where a lot of
comics when they're around each other,
um,
it becomes an issue sometimes because
they kind of mimic each other's personas
or,
or maybe just the cadence.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Start picking up.
Well,
there's a guy named David towl.
It's like one of the funniest guys ever.
And uh,
he's got a way of talking
that's really fun.
And when he talks,
like there's so many young guys that come
up that star talking like Dave a towel
and it's like,
it became an issue where there
was like all these little,
like Patrice O'Neal Eastcom tell babies.
There was all these,
uh,
tell babies that were running around it.
But it really,
they're just young comics
that admire is sorta Kate in.
They're trying to do it too.
And they were like super inspired because
they're young and they're just trying
to make it,
and then to seeing this guy who's this,
you know,
like fantastic comedian,
like,
and then they don't even realize it,
but they're just adopting it.
Yeah.
No,
that makes perfect sense.
I mean,
you just,
uh,
it becomes a template.
Yeah.
Nobody exists in a vacuum.
Right?
I mean,
everybody sort of,
there's the,
everyone influences everyone
around to a certain extent.
We all want to believe that we're some
rogue independent operator that exists
out in the fringe of society and lives
in a fucking wooden house in the woods
somewhere.
That sounds nice.
It sounds nice,
but it's a,
it's a k it's a creation of fiction.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
no,
and it's funny,
I some of the um,
uh,
someone I admire,
Clive Thompson,
he writes a lot about technology
for like wired and your times.
Um,
and he had a book out recently about,
you know,
is technology changing our brain.
And the opening chapter says,
you know,
newsflash,
everything changes your brain.
This sentence you just read,
it changed your rain.
Right?
So I mean on one hand it's sort of
silly to look at research that says,
Oh,
games change your brain
like this or you know,
music changed everything like that.
Um,
because everything you do,
everything you're exposed to changes
your rain and you're making a memory or
your,
your sort of activating a pattern.
Um,
so I mean like even this conversation,
you know,
congratulations like you
have changed my brain today,
but this is just something to think about,
like a lot of responsibility and I
know how we interact with each other.
Yeah.
It is.
And,
well,
that's one of the weirdest things about
doing a podcast is how many people will
tell me after they listened to
podcasts for our 500 episodes,
dude,
you changed my life.
Oh yeah.
Good.
It's a lot of responsibility,
but we really are changing
each other's lives.
I mean,
the podcast has changed my life.
Just being able to talk to
all these different people.
It's why it's important not to
have dip shits and your life.
Because if you're around people that
are just constantly fucking up and
constantly making the same
mistakes over and over again,
like that pattern affects you too.
Yeah.
That pattern will creep into your mind.
Yes.
Well then say,
you know,
it's,
it's really good to try and yourself
with people who inspire you because they,
they talk about having a cognitive
model for behavior change.
Like if you're trying to
get better in some way,
uh,
if you can visually,
if you know somebody who's already done
it or doing positive things in their
lives,
it's,
it requires less energy for your
brain to imagine yourself doing it.
Like,
if you're,
if you don't,
if you're not trying to be anybody who's
trying to get healthy or trying to get
fit or whatever it is,
um,
it's like,
it's literally harder to imagine.
And so it's like more exhausting for
you to try to imagine yourself getting
better.
Whereas if you're surrounded
by people who are doing it,
it becomes familiar to your brain.
There's all sorts of examples
that your brain can call on.
It literally takes less energy for you
to imagine yourself actually doing it.
And weirdly,
they found at Stanford University using,
uh,
like avatars.
If you can see an Avatar that
is designed to look like you,
like doing the sort of
things you want to do,
like,
you know,
being really physically fit,
like working out in the game world.
If you just watch an avatar customer
design to look like you doing that,
it lowers the cognitive
threshold for you to do it.
And then you will do more in real life.
You leave,
you know,
you will work out more or you'll spend
more time committed to those goals just
by having watched the sort of mirror
version of yourself having done it.
That's fascinating that,
that's fascinating because that seems to
open up a whole new of possibility for
people creating virtual realities.
Yeah.
Like virtual realities where you're,
what,
like one of the big things that they
say it's an important for progress in
sports and,
and in pretty much
anything is visualization.
Visualize yourself doing things.
It's a big thing with martial arts.
They,
uh,
take a lot of fighters.
They,
they,
they talk them through their scenarios.
They've,
they will sit down and the close her
eyes and meditate and visualize a
themselves getting out of bad situations,
visualize themselves winning and do it
over and over and over again to the point
where it becomes like a part
of this is your reality.
Your reality is you win.
Yeah.
You know,
it seems like if you could watch a
video of you doing all those things and
artificially created you yup.
Absolutely.
Jumping higher than
you've ever jumped before.
Did scoring and tennis or,
yeah.
So it's like,
it's,
there's a little bit of nuance
to it that's really interesting.
So,
um,
for example,
if you are like walking on a treadmill
while you're watching a custom avatar of
yourself and the Avatar,
you know,
starts running faster
and is getting fitter,
you will run faster,
you will,
you will work harder.
If you are engaged in an activity,
it can really,
uh,
get you moving.
So it was like,
it would be good to tie it to
when you're actually working out.
Like it might not be,
it might not last for,
you know,
I watched this movie today and a week
later I'm still feeling more powerful.
You kind of want to do it in the moment.
Um,
are they the one study at
Sanford found for 24 hours?
They were safe,
sort of,
were more physically active,
like taking stairs or doing
more pushups or whatever.
Um,
but uh,
but I do like the idea of
using it perfectly like that.
The one thing they know is like
for positive visualization,
I don't know if you've seen,
there's been new research coming out
that you have to visualize the effortful
action and not the outcome.
Like if you're visualizing getting,
you know,
lifted up on people with people shoulders,
like I'm the champion.
Um,
that actually seems to sometimes have a
counter productive effect because your
brain can imagine it so vividly.
You kind of feel like you've
already had that payoff and your,
you put in less effort that does ms
studies for a few years at show this.
Um,
so,
uh,
but if you're visualizing the effortful
activity that it takes to get there,
you're picturing,
you know,
here's what I have to do on game
day and you're thinking about,
um,
the,
the things that require effort on
your part techniques or you know,
the,
the actions you're going to take.
Um,
that is helpful.
So you just don't want to think about,
you know,
I can't wait til they,
call me up and say that I won.
Right.
Whatever you have,
you can't think about it.
Just,
you have to be visualizing the things
that are going to require effort and
energy on your part.
That's the,
that's that seems to be the most help.
It's so fascinating because like
just that statement right there,
that seems to be the most helpful.
There's so much weirdness
and all this is so it's,
it's like magic.
Like what the fuck is going on?
Like what the,
with the visualization process,
what's the mechanism like what,
what,
what is it an inspiration?
I mean how much of inspiration,
how much is inspiration
a factor in success?
I would say probably gigantic.
Right?
So is that all right?
I mean there's,
there's so many different avenues I am,
I focus on self efficacy as
what you're trying to increase.
Uh,
as opposed to inspiration.
So self efficacy is when you feel like
you have the skills and abilities and
resources you need to achieve your goal.
And it's,
it's,
it's different from self esteem.
Self esteem is like,
Oh,
I'm a good person United.
Sort of like myself.
Self efficacy is very specific.
Like,
if I have self efficacy
about running a marathon,
it means that I have done and you know,
at least a few 20 mile runs.
I know how hard it's going to be.
I've got my receipt,
I know how to,
you know,
fuel during the Ron.
I know how much I hate to take sodium.
I have to take a different points.
I know what the course looks like,
so I've got a mental plan.
Having that sense of reasonable optimism
and focusing on visualizing what you'll
do successfully that's focused on your
own skills and abilities that in all of
the scientific literature is
linked to better outcomes.
Whereas if you're imagining things
that are outside of your control,
it just doesn't because how is it
might inspire you and maybe you'll,
you know,
get out of bed and put
more of an effort as you,
you know,
picture something good happening to you.
But the,
the mental model that seems to be most
powerful is when you're focusing on
things that you have direct control over,
if that makes sense.
Yeah.
The self efficacy.
Well,
how much of all that is just a little,
what you were talking about is just
focus is just thinking about what you're
doing and the more you think about what
you're doing and the more energy you put
towards what you're
doing makes you better.
And how much of this is just mean?
Is it possible that all these ideas of
just visualization is what you're doing
is really just focusing more and
loving more what you're doing?
I think that could be a big part of it.
I mean,
the,
the focus attention it,
you're,
you're able to perform better,
you learn faster.
I think part of it is also something
to do with the dopamine system.
Um,
you know,
in video games.
So if some,
so I've talked to lots of neuroscientists,
um,
for this book and um,
a lot of them will say if you wanna
increase someone's self efficacy,
you have them play a video game.
Because I'm in a video game,
you're constantly required to
take action and then wait to see,
you know what,
I try to fire my weapon.
I wait to see if I shot successfully.
I try to orient around an obstacle,
I'm going to see,
I'm going to get information every time
that your brain expects information
about your performance,
it gives you a little dopamine
release and dopamine feels good.
So you got excited.
Um,
but increased open mean also allows you
to pay closer attention and to learn
faster,
right?
So anytime you're trying something
where you're constantly taking actions,
getting feedback and you have
to kind of learn and improve,
uh,
you'll get all this dopamine going and
that is associated with the ability to
build self efficacy.
So I think that there is a,
I mean,
I think there's a neurochemical
process that's underlying this.
It's not,
it's not just,
um,
I mean it's not just a matter of,
of what you think.
It's also about changing what is going
on in your brain so that the brain is
primed to learn faster to improve.
And that's um,
that's,
um,
that's why,
you know,
that's why there seemed to be so many
cool applications for video games because
if you can get a cancer patient who
feels really powerless and overwhelmed to
play a video game about chemotherapy
and it starts building self advocacy and
getting all the dopamine going,
there was a clinical trial that showed
that kids who played a video game about
cancer,
we're for two to three months later
missing fewer doses of their medicine,
taking more antibiotics,
they were more engaged,
um,
which leads to more cases of
cancer being going into remission.
Right?
But isn't that just more focus?
Just focusing and thinking,
man,
it's using it as a mechanism to
focus and think about your illness,
focus and think about your recovery.
It's focused with the dopamine hit and
the increased over mean is gonna it,
it,
it changes what's,
well now we'll get really deep here.
Um,
every time that you consider a goal,
your brain stops and says,
is it worth it?
Because your brain is trying to conserve
your body's energy and you know,
they're the,
your cognitive energy.
And we'll say,
if I,
if I do this goal,
am I,
do I really want it?
Am I going to put the energy to do it?
And what researchers have found is the
more dopamine you have in your reward
pathways,
the more you focus on the positive
outcome and the less you think about the
effort required.
So if I give you a bunch of dopamine hits,
you're going to be thinking about,
I might be cured someday.
I don't care how many side effects
there are to this medicine.
I'm swallowing this pill,
you know,
and,
and I'm going to do it because you're
focused on the positive outcome,
not all of the other things that
stress you out about it or make you,
you know,
the nausea and the,
the,
the energy that it takes.
And this is true if you're doing push ups,
you know,
like,
do I really feel like doing
a hundred pushups right now?
Um,
if you have more dopamine going,
you're going to be more likely to say,
this is important to me.
It's part of my training.
Um,
and if you are low dopamine,
which is when you're clinically depressed,
you have really load open mean.
So everything seems too hard.
Oh,
why am I going to bother
getting out of bed?
There's like the effort required seems
so much more important than the goal.
So there is a neurological underpinning
to self advocacy is sort of this
combination of really wanting to achieve
your goal and having that increased
attention so you learn faster.
So there's,
but you have to,
it's,
I mean,
it's not,
it's not just a matter of saying,
I'm going to pay attention.
Now you have to be priming your brain
to increase the dopamine and your reward
pathways.
Right?
But the dopamine hit.
What is the mechanism that
creates the dopamine hit?
Is it just simply loving
what you're doing,
you know?
No,
no,
no.
It's gold.
It's anticipation.
What specifically?
It's anticipation of feedback.
So the fastest way for like,
you want it to increase
your dopamine right now,
I would say make a prediction about
something that's going to happen today.
Um,
it could be anything.
I could,
I predict that song go,
we'll win today and four sets,
whatever it is.
You make a prediction about something.
Every time you make a prediction,
your brain's like,
oh,
I might be right.
I'm going to m n and that'll feel good.
And if I'm not right,
I'll learn something.
Why did he lose in five sites or whatever.
So I make a better prediction next time.
That gives you a dope me.
And so in a video game,
when you fire your weapon,
you have predicted that it's going to
successfully shoot that guy over there and
you're waiting for to see on the screen.
Did I miss or did I hit?
That's why you get a dopamine hit.
So every time you make a prediction,
your brain jeers up to either
celebrate that you were right,
Yay success or I got to learn so
that I can do better the next time.
That's why I think I,
you know,
I have friends,
I have one friend in particular that
didn't grow up with any healthy sense of
competition and it's,
he's actually talked about that.
Like if there's one thing that
he could go back and do again,
like he thinks his parents didn't really
instill any sense of competition in
him.
And he's one of those guys,
if he's playing a game,
it's not going his way.
He'll pull the plug.
Oh,
he'll flip the board over.
He's that guy.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
you know what's going on in the brain.
So this is,
you have this reaction,
but to him losing is just devastating
and write James or only if you can win.
Right.
Well,
and,
and it's probably what's going on.
It's his brain is saying,
you know,
it's starting to realize no amount of
effort is going to turn this around.
And so he just walks away.
No,
there's no,
well,
not only that,
there's no,
there's no history of figuring
things out and getting better.
Right.
Everybody who has ever started anything
and gotten really good at it and knows
it in the beginning,
you suck.
And it's some,
it's kind of exciting.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
you,
you pick something up,
say a tennis,
you know,
like if I started to playing tennis today,
I don't know how to play tennis.
I would suck and it would be exciting
because I would get my ass kicked on.
I'd be like,
okay,
I have to figure this fucking thing out.
Like what makes that ball spin like that?
How's that guy whacked that ball?
Oh,
I see.
He's,
no,
he knows he's number crunching.
He's gay.
He's like data.
He knows he's got,
he's chunking information.
He knows that if I move left,
the ball's going to go there
and he's going to go here and,
Huh,
okay.
And I don't have that.
So,
and that experience of getting better,
I mean,
that's the basis for self efficacy.
Um,
so it's like,
sometimes people ask me,
like parents will say,
what kids should my,
what game should my kids be
playing for a learning experience?
But I say every game is designed to be
a learning experience because you're
supposed to be bad.
And that's why games feel
so good is that you're,
you're,
every time you play a new game,
you're figuring it out.
You're learning how it works,
you're getting better.
That experience of constantly getting
better and proving to yourself,
I can figure something out.
I can improve,
I can master something.
Um,
that's,
I mean that's one of the reasons this
is a fundamental reason why people like
playing games and why they don't
play the same game forever.
I mean sometimes you do if the game
that you can never master like chess or
something,
you know,
but most people will,
will really get into a game for a while
and then feel like they have stopped
improving.
And so the brain gets,
you know,
wants to keep learning,
wants to keep getting better.
The dopamine hits are only gonna come
if you aren't sure how to be successful.
Right.
So you have to play a new game.
So why we don't play
Tic Tac toe is adults,
right?
Nope.
No.
Dopamine hits from tic TAC toe.
Cause you know exactly
what's going to happen.
Yeah.
Bullshit game and keep trying
to tell my five year old,
it's going to be a draw
every time kids bullshit.
Um,
but there's,
there's a,
a lead ism attached to chess.
Chess is the only game.
It's considered a,
a,
a worthwhile pursuing.
Now it's terrible.
What is that?
Because parents will tell kids that are
playing video games and they're wasting
their time.
I know,
but if you came home when your kid was
playing chess silently with his friend
and they're just looking at the,
he be like,
oh,
my kid is up to a good thing.
Okay,
sure.
I mean,
first because Einstein play chess so well,
I think that's part of it.
Although,
you know,
it's really interesting if
you read letters that he
used to write fucking hated
chess.
No,
he loved it.
But he wrote to people that he was
worried that he was addicted to it.
He talked a lot about how,
how he had this game addiction,
which is fascinating when
you think about today,
how many people worried about,
I'm addicted to world of
Warcraft or whatever game.
So even Einstein worried
about being addicted
to his favorite game.
It is real game addiction
is absolutely real.
It is.
It is
a real,
um,
uh,
it is absolutely real.
And uh,
there are techniques for
breaking that pattern by the way,
if you would,
do you want it quick
technique for how to break?
Sure.
Okay.
There's a whole chapter in,
in the Super Better Book about
the game addiction and how,
how to stop it,
how to reverse it.
Um,
and what tends to lead people into it.
Yeah.
Biggest that's my friend Duncan was on,
uh,
biggest addict I know to video
games always have me feel normal.
Uh,
the biggest predictor for,
uhW,
who will become addicted to games and
feel like it kind of gets out of control
spirals out of control is if they're
playing for escapist purposes to try to
block other feelings.
Like,
I have these,
all these problems,
I'm going to play the game instead.
I'm,
I'm feeling anxious,
I'm going to play the game and said,
um,
so the way you reverse it is you,
you have to,
I mean,
I talk about it as playing to get better.
You are instead of playing
to avoid something,
you focus on what you're doing
that is making you better.
Even if it's just to start
getting better at this game,
then you focus on,
you know,
why I'm playing with,
I,
my friends is like improving
my relationships or I'm
focusing on strategy or
building my teamwork
skills or whatever it is.
You start to think about,
um,
other goals outside the game that
the game is connected to because the
biological process of addiction is
the narrowing of goals that the brain
responds to.
This is true for,
for drug addiction.
I mean,
all forms of addiction,
pornography,
narrowing of goals at the brain response,
right?
So,
you know,
I said,
you get like this dopamine hit.
When you anticipate something good in,
in addiction,
the brain starts to believe that the only
source of the next dopamine hit is the
thing you're addicted to.
And you can't imagine other things that
are gonna make you feel that good or
feel that excited.
And one of,
there's this great new book called
the biology of desire that lays a
neuroscientist,
kind of lays out all the
new thinking on addiction.
And the way that you break,
one of the ways you break out of cycle
for any addiction is to start priming the
brain to anticipate success
or pleasure from other things.
So you have to just talk about like
widening the scope of what is going to
provide that dopamine hit.
So in game play you have to stop,
um,
you have to stop thinking about the
game as the only source of that,
that,
that good feeling.
So you have to start thinking about other
goals that you have besides just the
sort of sense of relief that
the game is going to provide.
Um hmm.
So
that's something that they tell addicts
that are drug addicts use channel at
addiction into something else.
So that's essentially what they're saying.
They're saying,
well,
you need to do is find something else,
but that's positive that
you can get addicted to.
Yeah.
So you're seeking out that weird
chemical reaction in the mind,
right.
When you're stimulated by something else.
Right.
And instead of chasing
crack you'll chase exercise.
Yes.
But in what we're seeing with games,
because games aren't inherently dangerous,
you don't have to quit playing games.
And in fact it can be dangerous to just
go cold Turkey on games because it's
like taking someone off an
antidepressant without tapering them.
Because Games have such
a powerful impact on our,
our happiness.
You know how the kids are
going to listen to this go mom,
it's dangerous for me to quit this game.
[inaudible] Jane,
they're like suicide.
I mean their cases of kids who have
killed themselves when their parents turn
off the game and those kids would
have killed themselves over anything.
I I think,
I think it is likely related to,
it's the same thing when you take
someone off and ended a precedent and the
brain is no longer having that.
Uh,
it's like dope.
You,
you,
you lose your ability to imagine.
Is the term it positive?
Is the term addiction?
Like is that a flawed term?
Like it,
cause it seems like it's so
limited and so narrow in its scope.
We,
we think of addiction,
we think of always on the heroin,
you know,
like you just automatically think,
but really what is it that your brain
has locked into these pathways of
achieving desirable effects?
Absolutely.
Um,
and that's,
there's a lot,
I've,
I've done some work with some
real real rotation centers,
recovery centers for addiction where
they're starting to be more aware of this,
the new sense of what addiction is.
Um,
but if people are interested,
the book that just came out this year
about that the biology of desire does a
really good job of
explaining it because it's,
I mean,
the,
it's a pretty provocative argument.
It says that addiction is not a disease.
It's,
it's a fun,
it's,
the brain is functioning
absolutely perfectly.
It's just focusing on,
it's like hyper focusing on one goal.
But if you had that same brain chemistry
about running a startup company,
I mean,
Mark Zuckerberg was addicted
to his startup in the same
way that someone can get
addicted to a video game
or addicted to a substance,
you get hyper focused on one goal.
It's your only source of,
of pleasure and anticipation of,
um,
these positive feelings.
So it's,
the brain is working properly.
It's not broken.
It's not,
it's not a disease in that sense.
It's that,
uh,
it has just gotten stuck on
a particular productive yeah.
That,
that is maybe ultimately not good for
you physically are not good for your,
the life that you're trying to leave
career a good rest for
your family life or,
yeah.
I had a buddy that was addicted to,
um,
one of those role playing games,
trying to,
I guess it was everquest and,
uh,
he,
he had this really profound statement
we were at the comedy store wants,
he was one of the managers and uh,
he said,
I am so good at making money in my online
life and so bad at it in my real life.
Yeah.
And like he was like,
he was sitting there like a broken man.
And I'm like,
how often?
He plays like eight hours,
nine,
10 hours a day.
Every day.
Yeah.
I go every day.
And he goes,
yeah,
I,
um,
I can't not play it.
And then that's when he said that like,
um,
it was like this rare break from
the game on during his free time.
He wasn't working and he came down to
the comedy store to hang out and he's
pasty white Pale like almost gray skinned.
Yeah.
Cause he was just like,
just drained mound Nurus sitting
in front of a monitor all the time,
clicking and moving.
Right.
Yeah.
And so it's like the
intervention for that,
you know,
if you were to sort of
follow the guidelines,
uh,
of,
of how you try and get people to sort of
focus on other goals is you would just
start by asking him,
well,
why are you good at
making money in this game?
What,
what,
what does it take in terms of
skill or commitment or reserve?
What are you,
what are you doing?
And,
and,
and start to think about
strengths and abilities.
And then,
um,
when you are thinking about yourself
and what you're good at and what you're
capable of,
it kind of takes you out of,
you own it.
It's not the game,
right?
The game isn't making
you successful or happy.
It's your own skills and abilities.
And that seems to be,
if you look at the scientific literature,
just talking about what you own and what,
what is a result of your
skills and abilities that
that helps you broaden that.
So you realize you can
apply that elsewhere.
There might be other venues.
It's not the game that's giving this
to me and this is something that I own.
Right.
That's so hard to intellectualize.
Now when you're in the grips of addiction.
I know,
I know.
It's why this is just like questions in
my book that like literally you can ask
someone or you can ask yourself so that
you don't have to intellectualize it.
And we just do the,
so the,
there are a hundred quests in the book.
You just do what I do.
What I tell you to do.
They're all designed like
little game missions.
Um,
because it is,
it is,
it is hard to change your mindset.
I mean,
it's definitely hard,
but what we know from studies of all kinds
of mindset interventions is that once
you do it,
it sticks.
So unlike a lot of forms
of therapy or medication,
you have to take this pill
for the rest of your life.
You have to be in therapy for years.
If you can do a mindset intervention,
it's done,
benefits are there,
it's locked in and you can have a
five minute mindset intervention and,
and instead of taking,
you know,
prescription for the rest of your life.
What I've found to mitigate my addiction
problems or my addictive tendencies is
just do a bunch of different things.
Yup.
I have a bunch of different activities
that I do and the reason why I'm doing so
many different things is
to keep from locking out.
Right,
exactly.
So you've like intuitively
figured that out.
All right.
Okay.
Well I figured it out from trial and
error over a long life of addiction.
I grew up being addicted to
a bunch of different things.
At first it was art and
then it became martial arts.
And then as I got older it became
standup comedy and it became a pool.
I had a real problem with pool to a
point where my manager thought it was
ruining my career.
Oh my God,
I was playing eight,
10 hours a day.
I was playing in tournaments.
All I want to do was play pool.
I would go do my comedy sets and
then I go play pool till three,
four o'clock in the morning.
And then I would get up in
the morning and go workout.
I go,
uh,
you know,
go do my comedy and do the
same thing every night and all.
But all I was thinking about was the game.
I was thinking about like
knocking the balls into the hole.
Like the,
they're the dopamine effect
or whatever it is of,
of winning,
of or of being successful,
of running out the table of having
the ball do what you want it to do.
Yeah.
And because it's so difficult,
the reward is so much like
anything that's really,
like if you play a game,
it's really easy,
but when you win it doesn't mean anything.
But when you play a game
that's really hard to do.
That reward is so
fucking exciting.
Yeah.
But this is interesting cause like you
become a more interesting person as a
result of having all
the things that you do.
Like you're like this really unusual
that you have all of these things instead
of being hyper focused on one aspect.
Um,
so it's probably,
I mean it seems like a good strategy.
I'm just a broad spectrum junkie.
That might be,
that could be like a recipe
for a good life though.
I mean I,
this is kind of independent,
interested in that idea now.
Like what you should that should,
that should be like a thing,
broad spectrum junkie.
I mean it works right now,
but it could go off the rails.
Yeah.
Well you gotta keep,
you gotta keep,
you gotta keep that circle why it's
going off the rails several times in my
life.
But it's just,
she was like,
even I like with running,
like I,
I definitely use running
for my mental health.
Um,
and if I get an injury
that is really hard for me.
I have to replace it
with something or else,
you know,
you go into a depression.
It's a big thing with Jujitsu guys.
It's very difficult for them to take the
time off before they go back and train
again once they get injured.
Yeah.
And I have a cup of chronic injuries
that I have because one particular of a
back injury,
there was a bulging
disc that I just would,
I would ignore.
Right.
I would,
I would hurt it pretty bad.
And then two weeks later
I'd be sparring again.
Yeah.
Because I was just needed that rush.
Until it got pretty chronic.
And then I had to take a long stretch
off and really let it heal up.
But it,
can you give me that perspective?
It feels like,
I mean,
just hearing you say that makes me think
how really how important is for people
to understand like how this
system works so that you can say,
look,
my brain's telling me to
go back and work out now.
Even though my doctor said don't
do it and I can Google and it says,
stay off it for six weeks.
Um,
and to understand your brain is telling
you that because it wants a dopamine
hit.
If you really want to
rehabilitate properly,
you need to start doing other
things that produce dopamine hits.
And that's,
I mean,
fantasy sports for example.
Do you get really into that for
the season that you're taking off?
Um,
because that's you're making predictions,
so that's really,
that's not good work.
It wouldn't work for you.
No chance works for a lot of people
playing poker then not you need to be
active.
Physically active.
Yeah.
There there's has to be actual physical
movement and fucking that nervousness is
a big part of my adrenaline junky thing.
Yeah.
It's actual nerves.
It's like playing poker is,
it was never exciting to me.
Even if like people are
gambling for a lot of money,
whereas playing pool is extremely
exciting because there's the execution,
the physical explanation of things.
So you're going into flow state.
Yeah,
that's what that is,
right?
Too much.
Well,
I think my brain was wired with
martial arts and competing,
which is extremely exciting,
but dangerous and thrilling
and the thrills or so high,
like the thrills of competing or just
beyond anything that you can ever get from
something that's
nonphysical nonthreatening.
It's,
it's high level problem solving with
dire physical health consequences.
Right.
So there's all sorts of craziness involved
in it and the intensity and the focus
that you need.
So you that guy on the skateboard
really well then.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Two well that's what's
scary about it to me.
Yeah.
That could have fucking easily been
me when I was 17 or 18 years old.
I understand all that shit.
That's why one of the things that freaked
me out the most about those people
that are tight rope walking
and doing all the jumping,
those squirrel suits or they jump
off of cliffs and fly around.
Yeah.
That doesn't know.
It freaks me out is that I get it.
Yeah.
That's what freaks me out.
Race,
car driving,
all that shit is like,
I understand what this guy's doing.
He's feeding that monster in his brain
that needs to be shocked and scared and
thrilled and what's next and you know,
it's like you feel alive,
not just feel alive but hyper.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Hyper alive in a very hot,
it's funny cause you were asking about
focus earlier and obviously when you go
into that like the intense state
where there is high stakes,
high risk,
your attention,
it's so super focused,
a time slows down and you're
able to see more process more.
So that could be part of,
I mean did you,
you're interested in,
in focus because that's a part
of that experience at high,
which you don't get.
There's,
I mean there's lots of highs
where you're not going to happen.
That's kind of heightened
focus and attend.
There's that and there's this state
of peace that's achieved when you've
overcome almost insurmountable
obstacles and fear and nervousness,
everything else,
like whatever weird problems
that you might be dealing with,
with your personal life.
They seem so inconsequential.
Like,
uh,
like when I would have like a
relationship problems or girl,
I was dating some craziness.
We're about to break up.
I would go spar and I would be like,
who gives a fuck?
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and you know,
I would,
I remember one time having
this conversation with
this girl I was dating was
like so dramatic and nonsense.
I'm like,
so then I guess we're breaking up.
I mean,
like what,
what are we going to do?
Like I fuck,
I can't do this.
Like either we like each other
or we don't like each other.
Either they're going to hang out and
have fun or we're not going to hang out
anymore.
Like,
I don't want to do this anymore.
oh,
you're so cold,
your early twenties.
Yeah,
sure.
Fucking to do you really gain perspective
instead of wallowing around in this,
because I think there's an addictive
aspect of relationships to breakup,
makeup thing of the,
the highs and the lows of like,
there are some people that are
addicted to arguing in relationships.
Oh,
sure.
Falling in love is an addiction.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
it's literally the same process.
It's the narrowing of
attention on one day.
The only that person gets you
that excited gets you that,
um,
the bunch of biological tricks.
Yeah.
Age too,
because your body's trying
to get you to breed.
Yeah.
And what's really,
then you get the really problematic
relationships when that happens for one
person and not the other.
And that's why you get stalkers.
Yeah.
Well you get like,
but it's like,
it's why it's why somebody
seems you don't understand.
Even if you're dating and you
kind of liked that person,
but they're already there down the road.
They're like,
they are there,
they are in love,
they are addicted.
And then your behavior might seem totally
crazy to me because I'm not there yet.
And even though I liked you,
because you're further along in that
process and that sort of narrowing of
attention,
uh,
I freak out where it's,
you know,
maybe if I had waited a few more weeks,
I might've been that I might've been far
enough along that it actually doesn't
scare me off.
You know,
like people who fall in
love at different rates.
It's not,
it's not totally though that you're a
crazy person and I'm a normal person and
therefore I shouldn't date you.
It's just your further,
the biochemical processes
look a little faster for you.
Um,
it was,
I think like there are couples who break
up too soon because one of them came
kind of cut further along in the addiction
process and the other what a weird
way to look at it.
But yeah,
I mean,
and also it's like the same exact person.
You could meet them six months
later and they're perfect,
right?
Yeah.
Or you meet them right now because
maybe they have enough going on yeah.
In their life that they
fall in love slower.
Sure.
Right.
Because you'll fall in love faster if
there's nothing else getting you excited
in your day.
Right.
Well,
it's also that term fall in love.
Like what,
what exactly is going on there?
Like what does that mean?
Right.
You know,
you're just sinking up
whatever personality aspects
that you have holes and
square pegs in round holes and everyone's
trying to figure out where everything
fits in.
And then there's also a weird thing where,
uh,
we've all had friends that alter who
they are when they start dating someone.
Yeah.
It's very strange to see too,
you know,
like they'll stop talking to some of their
friends or they change their behavior
pretty radically and you're like,
Whoa,
what's going on?
You're like fitting in to this
mold of the other person requires.
Yeah.
Like one person is either more dominant
or you're both like super fucking
codependence.
So you need each other all the time.
Yeah.
I have a friend.
This motherfucker can't go
anywhere without his girlfriend.
He doesn't do anything without her.
I mean,
Eh,
w invite them over for a podcast.
Boom.
Brings his girlfriend,
you know,
come on over for the game.
Oh,
she's here to great.
You know,
like he doesn't go to the movies,
didn't do anything like they were like,
does he,
is he happy?
It's a fucking mess.
He's a mess.
But the two of them are a mess together
and it's like in escapable pair.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
That may,
they're happy,
messy,
happy.
Maybe.
I Dunno.
I don't know either.
Okay.
Well,
what is happiness?
That's strange.
I mean,
it's like they're not depressed.
They're not jumping off bridges.
Yeah.
You know,
the Bolton,
they're not shooting heroin
and that was all sounds good.
Yeah.
Like what,
what is it that makes people
addicted to each other?
Cause they most certainly
get addicted to each other.
Yeah.
Like the feeling when someone breaks up
with you when you can't believe they're
gone.
Yeah.
Like that is like,
I'll like someone's
stolen something from you.
Like they've stolen your happiness by
taking off and just simply leaving you
alone.
Yup.
You,
they are,
they are a part of you like your whole,
your,
your whole is missing a slice.
Yeah.
Like the whole of,
I know that
it means all the
metaphors that people use.
It really does feel that way.
Yeah.
But isn't that a biological trick?
Just to get us to breed,
like you stick around long
enough to make a baby and then,
you know,
fall in love with the baby so
that you raise it and so that,
that baby can go and have a baby in the
sense of community that you have all
sorts of is addictive and
it keeps you together,
which ensures survival.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
that's why cooperation feels good.
It's why kindness feels good.
I mean,
I'm still tricky.
It is.
And it's like,
I don't know.
You can,
I mean,
I'm a very practical person.
I mean I think I try to
help people feel good.
I want to feel good,
know,
cooperation and kindness.
You know,
those things help society
and help evolution and like
we're stronger together.
Yeah.
And it feels good.
Uh,
like that's,
that's practical and you
and I don't mind that.
And you know,
evolution is kind of tricking me.
I mean,
I have two babies.
I have a seven month old twin daughters.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
if,
if this is a trick of biology,
how I feel about them,
I'm totally cool with that
because it feels good.
Yeah.
That's biology's trick to me.
It tells me it feels good.
I like it.
Thank you.
Biology for giving me these
feelings I never have before.
Yeah.
I mean you can kind of intellectualize
it down to the point where it's no longer
enjoyable cause he's,
it isn't life itself a trick in a sense
because it's really temporary no matter
what.
You can accumulate all the Audis and,
and beautiful houses and boats you want,
but the end of the day it's over.
You know,
like you use the sunrises and sunsets
and you've got a certain amount of time
and that's it.
So you can intellectualize that
to the point where we're like,
well then what's the fucking point?
I'm just going to end it now.
And some people do do that.
They almost get to this thing where
they can't be in the moment because they
don't know how long the moment lasts.
And the anticipation of the
moment ending is just too freaky.
So like fuck this,
I'm out.
It's sort of the same thing as my friend
who can't play the video game if he's
going to lose and he pulls the plug.
I mean really there's a lot of lot
of the same sort of qualities and
characteristics of that kind of thinking.
I was like,
there's over intellectualizing or over
analyzing to the point where you can't
even enjoy what it is.
I feel like I really want to work on
this friend of yours like a figure like
video games therapy to like,
well it sounds like an
interesting project EGOMANIAC.
You don't want to do it too much problems.
I like by like I liked,
they do.
Like how would you help
somebody who can't lose
usually be so happy that you're trying
to help them because that means you're
talking about him.
It's like you're focusing on him.
It was a lot of awe but no,
I mean he's alive.
He lives in America is not an
Ethiopia living in a grass house,
you know?
It's like he's lucky as fuck.
Yeah.
You got to think I,
I,
it's at a certain point
in time that there's,
there's,
there's levels to,
to like happiness and harmony,
the harmony that you achieve with the
environment that you find yourself in and
the more chaos that you create and the
more problems that you create just to
solve those problems.
It's got it,
that that energy keeps you from doing
something else and that energy is going to
block you from the other pursuits.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean,
you need to take committed
action towards positive things
and in a sense,
the entirety of your life
is again,
of course.
Yes,
it is.
I have a kind of funny story about that.
Um,
you know,
I did the Colbert report a few
years ago and when you did that,
she'd break character.
So when he comes,
not,
no,
not well,
not exactly.
He comes in the dressing room beforehand
and they don't do a pre show interview
because they want you to be kind
of off guard and off balance.
And he comes in and he says,
you know,
have you seen the show?
Okay,
I'm going to be in character and a,
I'm going to be really stupid and stubborn
and your job is to disabuse me of my
stupid and stubborn ideas.
Um,
and they said,
now let me ask you a question,
uh,
is,
you know,
his life,
a game.
And I was like,
is this,
is he like,
is he practicing,
you know,
is this like I am,
I,
are we practicing some kind of witty
rapport for the show or whatever.
So I'm like,
I'm trying to go into that mode.
And I'm like,
well,
you know,
yes,
of course it is.
And he's like,
if life is a game and we
spend all our time playing it,
why are we so bad at it?
And I'm like,
I'm like totally thrown off of Mike.
Is he being like Phyllis,
I don't like,
anyway,
it turned out he was actually being
quite philosophical and he had like,
he had all of these,
you know,
sort of thoughts about,
I mean,
we've started mentioning philosophy books,
he'd ride and everything.
And I was like,
oh,
okay,
this is like,
not like a,
you know,
ready like banter practice.
He was like,
really thinking about that.
And I always,
uh,
I have an,
I mean to return to that question and
try to come up with a better answer for
him someday.
Well,
it's a complicated game and
there's no instruction book.
That's why we're so bad at it.
I mean,
it's not everybody's bad
and you run into people,
you go,
wow,
this person is a really
cool game going on.
Yeah.
You know,
but it is just a game.
And essentially what the problem
is that there's loaded words,
like the word addiction is a loaded word.
It's a loaded term.
I think the word game
is a loaded term too.
It's a complicated series of events
that you're trying to manage.
Yup.
And you're trying to manage risk and
reward and benefit and then positive and
negative aspects of behavior.
Essentially.
It's exactly the same as the game.
They're completely indistinguishable.
Yeah.
It's one of them is just
open ended and there's,
you know,
there's no clear pathway.
It's a game that literally you're
standing in the middle of the universe,
Bam.
And especially in 2015 if you have the
means you can get on a plane and go to
another part of the game.
You know,
you could just hop on
a plane and you know,
we were talking before
this podcast started about,
uh,
the radio lab,
a podcast that's today,
um,
about that guy who was on my podcast,
Cory Nolton and shot that Rhino.
Like that's a guy who took the game
and decided to go to a fucking place.
He totally doesn't belong or has never,
you know,
never is not born there,
whatever shouldn't say doesn't belong,
but a completely different area of the
game and he's doing something over there
and everybody over on
this part of the game,
it's like,
what the fuck are you doing over there?
Like some guy gets on a boat and
decided to sail across the world,
right?
Like,
Whoa,
whoa.
What are you doing?
Right?
Well,
he decided that he's going to go to a
different part of the board and he's going
to get in a boat and he's going to drink
rainwater and tried to catch fish and
travel across the fucking ocean.
She's like,
people are playing,
right?
Different kinds of games.
So like the guy who wants to kill a rhino,
that's a combat game and the person
who wants to sail around in the boat is
doing exploration and adventure
game and other people are doing the,
you know,
collection game where you
are acquiring resources.
Everything that the Rhino guys
doing the collection game well,
yeah.
Weird way.
Right?
He's collecting bodies.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And I think the,
the guy who's on the boat is
doing the collection game too,
cause he's collecting accolades.
You know,
I've made it across the ocean.
Oh right.
Yeah.
The real way to do is go across the ocean.
Don't tell anybody.
Right.
Where are you bidding
for the last six months?
You know,
just chilling,
trying to find myself.
Well you know,
you were on a boat
when Isaiah to training for a marathon.
I was like,
I'm not telling anybody because I don't,
I want it to like just internal.
Yeah.
I want it to be from,
well you know,
cause it's like this weird bias some
people have about renters that like they
brag about it a lot or like
they do it to like show off
Gino who says that people
who wish they were running.
Oh I really believe that.
Yeah.
Cause if you run,
like I have my friend Cameron,
Cameron Hanes,
he's run two ultra marathons.
Hey he'll,
you know,
post about it on his Instagram or he'll
show you his time or something like
that.
But he's trying to,
like,
he's an athlete and these sponsored by
a bunch of companies and part of his Gig
is that he inspires people and
he really feels good about that.
It'll be genuine thing that he does,
takes people running up these mountains.
But you'll see these people
at like bitch about it.
Like this guy's running,
he's run a hundred miles in 24 hours.
If that's unimpressive,
not worth,
then you need to go look in the mirror
and find out what the fuck actually
impresses you.
You post a picture of your
breakfast you can't get mad about.
Yeah.
Okay.
Then yeah,
my eggs.
Yeah.
Yes.
I mean it's like,
well,
why do people get upset that you say
you're going to run a marathon and why
would anybody get upset?
It's hard to run a marathon.
You've got to run for three and a half,
four hours,
whatever the hell your time is.
Yeah.
That's up fucking long time.
It's hard for me to do 20 minutes on the
elliptical machine and not get bored.
Yeah.
I could keep going for a lot longer.
But at 20 minutes I'm like,
fuck,
am I done?
Jay is as Christ get this over with.
When someone says they ran a marathon,
you start to question your own resolve.
Yes.
Which is like one of the
reasons why they do it.
You're showing your score.
Yeah.
You're showing your game score
and people are getting pissed.
Yeah.
Too High.
Fucking showing her highest score.
But sometimes,
sometimes I will post a terrible run
cause I like you don't want to be too
inspiring that people feel
like they can't do it.
Like fuck those people.
I'll do it slow run so
that people will see like,
oh you're tricking you
into doing shitty scores.
They're tricking you.
That's true.
So true.
Well there's definitely that.
There's is a lot of people who when
someone will accomplish something I will,
I'm fascinated by watching the observers
and one of the Instagram observers of
the most fascinating cause
whenever I go to someone's page,
someone's done something cool.
Like you know my friend Cameron
running a hundred miles,
I'll look at the,
the,
the negative comments and I go to their
Instagram page and they're almost always
blocked.
It's almost always private,
like locked.
Like you,
you have to,
you have to be one of their accepted
friends on the comment on their pictures
because they're hiding.
Right.
Cause they're not putting
themselves out there.
Right.
They're not showing their life
and which means they don't understand
the vulnerability involved.
Like if you were,
if you had the experience of having
other people write on your stuff the same
way that you were doing on someone else,
you might not be doing that.
Well,
they're playing the low,
they're playing tic TAC toe,
right?
Yeah.
Or someone else's out there playing chess.
That's gotta be like the
new like zing my man.
You're playing tic TAC toe.
Yeah.
That's like tic Tac toe
play a mother fucker.
Yeah.
I mean it is kind of what it is.
If life is this really super complex,
open ended game where essentially if
you live in a free culture like we do,
you know,
we're not living in North Korea where
you're assigned a job and if you don't cry
when something happens,
you know,
you go to jail,
you,
your,
your game is essentially open ended.
Yep.
It's not,
that's one of the reasons why
when people get out of jail,
they find themselves like
institutionalize is the word,
but they find themselves so
trapped in the game of jail.
Yeah.
That's how their brain is wired.
It's really extremely difficult for
them to deal with the open ended game of
life.
Yeah.
I mean,
even for UC it with when
someone graduates college,
kids who have been from the top colleges
who have been taught to play the game
of achieving and achieving in
this really rigid structure,
and then they get out into the world
and nobody's telling them here,
here are the things you have to do
to be considered a good student or be
successful.
And then they just lose it.
It's too much.
Yeah.
Because they don't,
they are not,
they have not been
directing their own game.
Right.
It's like you,
if you,
if you haven't been designing the game
now you have to suddenly acquire that
skill.
It's also one of the problems that
some people have with career academics.
People that never participated
in the real world.
They went from college to teach
in college and then they also,
they require these rigid
standards of behavior and things.
I know,
I heard your show about that.
Yeah.
Dot.
The Atlantic article.
Awesome.
Yeah,
that is,
well,
it's interesting because I've been
so steeped in psychology literature,
um,
and uh,
a lot of the folks who play super
better are traumatized and they've,
they've been through PTSD and it is
absolutely true that avoiding triggers
prolongs the problem.
I mean,
so I,
I can look at the scientific literature
and say trigger warnings are actually
not,
they're not going to help.
They're going to make
you weaker over time.
It's like we were talking about,
you know,
oh,
I'm so scared of the bad guy.
I have to avoid everything
that is a trigger.
Um,
we know that that's not true.
So when I,
you know,
when I hear about that,
I,
you know,
I wish,
and I try to talk to people and I
tweet when that article came out,
I tweeted about it and I have a lot
of people who follow me who are,
you know,
have PTSD and they're very conflicted
about whether they're supposed to avoid
triggers and they like trigger warnings
cause they think it's going to keep them
safe.
But for everything we know is that you
need to get better at controlling your
reaction to the trigger.
Avoiding it doesn't help.
So I can,
I can see why that's so
frustrating to people.
Well,
the,
for the,
one of the most frustrating aspects
of that article in particular was that
what's going on in colleges today is it's,
it's a control issue.
Yeah.
It's,
they're controlling behavior in such
an extreme way that they're there.
They want to penalize people
for micro aggressions.
Right.
Which is like you say something and I go,
alright.
Which is just a part of a fucking
human interaction with it.
Like if I say something to you and
you give me a sarcastic response,
I have to decide,
you know what,
I don't enjoy communicating
with her because she,
she makes me feel bad.
Or I have to say maybe I'm fucking
Douchey and maybe people react to me in a
negative way and I should think about
not what I want to say or how I want to
say things,
but rather how people might view what
I'm saying and how they take it in.
And maybe I'm just an
ineffective communicator and
maybe what's going on here is
just,
you know,
there's,
there's like two people playing soccer.
Okay.
They're both trying to hit the ball
and they collide into each other.
Who's fault is it?
It's,
well,
they're both the,
it's just non smooth movement.
Yup.
And that,
that sort of interaction that you would
get when you're trying to hit a soccer
ball.
It's very similar to the interaction that
you had when two people communicating
with each other,
your e the colliding people.
One person is not necessarily totally
responsible for that collision.
Yeah.
They're both sort of responsible for it.
And there's a,
there's a,
a whole dance going on with poor
decision making in the moment and lack of
experience and collisions and lack of
an understanding of the consequences of
those collisions.
All that is a part of going to college
and all that is a part of growing up.
And when you have people that are
shielding you from micro aggressions.
Yeah.
All that shit is just a part of being a
human and dealing with your hormones and
emotions and yeah,
you're separated from your family for
the first time and now you're in Michigan
and some fucking crazy university
and you've got some fat,
stupid teacher that's never even
existed outside of the real world.
And they're dictating your
behavior patterns and telling
you you're not allowed
to use a male and female pronouns anymore.
And all this.
I liked the teachers.
I mean,
you know,
I have a lot of friends who are,
who are,
you know,
they teach at university,
so that was dry.
I will remove the fat,
stupid,
well I'm just surprised.
Let's say skinny smart
really yet or whatever.
I'm fat,
stupid.
Does that even mean like physically
what I mean is just like this,
this bloated sort of lazy entity that is
creating this environment where you're,
you're establishing this artificial realm.
So is looking at what's going on.
This is not coming from instructors or
faculty that this is coming from the
students and some of the phenomenon.
But it certainly,
it certainly was,
uh,
I mean it,
it,
it's,
this is definitely a younger phenomena.
It doesn't like something like
deeply entrenched people who came up.
I mean,
my professors are totally like friends
who are professors are totally weirded
out by it,
don't know how to handle it.
They're not creating that culture.
I mean,
it's definitely something coming from
the students who have been raised in this
culture of,
you know,
uh,
I mean it's that it's a very
protective culture and you don't,
nobody should have their feelings hurt.
Nobody,
you know,
nobody should experience
failure or rejection.
I mean,
I,
I feel like it's more from that culture
then from anything related to like
contemporary academia or faculty
thing because isn't contemporary academia
academia overwhelmingly liberal and
progressive?
Uh,
I mean,
I think so.
I think on the political spectrum,
yeah,
when you have something that's moving
in one very particular direction,
oftentimes people will try to outdo
themselves or are not in control.
I mean
this is,
I think the reason why a student culture
would have so much impact on this is
because universities are now like
business models and the customer is always
right.
I mean that's not,
the professor is not the one who is,
uh,
who is going to like the professors
more often than not resist.
It's really more at the level of,
uh,
the,
the business side of a college
that is trying to make,
you know,
this,
uh,
make,
make this a good customer
experience for the student.
I mean,
I think that is that
it's more of the divine.
I don't think the,
the political affiliations
of faculty is not,
I mean,
none of that is really what's going on.
It's really more about the students pay
so much money for college now and they
expect lots of perks
and they expect their,
they're paying for a certain experience.
Um,
I think that is really where you're
seeing a lot of the friction come because
that's particularly younger generation is,
um,
seems to be if you look at,
you know,
what a lot of the experts
are saying they want,
they don't want the things that feel
painful or feel like failure or feeling
stress.
Well,
if that's the case,
then why are they a pointing out all
these flaws and all these other people's
behavior to control them and flaws
in the way people express themselves.
Flaws.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
it's,
part of it is obviously
things need to change,
right?
I mean,
like what needs to change?
For instance,
I'm a woman.
I play games.
If I log into an online video game,
I don't want to be called a
comment every time I log in.
Does that happen a lot?
Yeah,
of course.
And do you think that happens a lot
because of what we talked about earlier,
where there's the interaction
of just dealing in text?
This is a very strange and the interaction
without people being right there with
each other.
Yes.
I mean,
absolutely.
Um,
seems like totally unnatural,
right?
Yes,
yes.
And people,
I mean,
I don't,
that doesn't happen to me in real life.
Right.
That's what I was going to ask.
Like how many people in real
life say those things to you?
Nobody.
Yeah.
Like how bizarre,
right?
Yeah.
All of a sudden you enter into this world.
So isn't that a function almost of the
world itself being completely unnatural,
more so than then the people
being any different in that world?
I'm not sure.
But I mean,
so all of those say
there are things that people say and do
in everyday life that are legitimately
offensive.
Sure.
Uh,
I mean,
I don't use the terminology
microaggressions,
I don't use it,
the trigger warning terminology.
So I think we're like in this period
where on one hand things do need to change
and some ways,
you know,
you,
you have Nobel laureate scientist giving
speeches where they say that it's,
he doesn't like to have women in the lab
because either they fall in love with
you or you fall in love with them
and then you can't work together.
I mean when some,
when a Nobel laureate says
that to a conference of,
you know,
young scientists that that's
not helpful I don't think,
but I know that that was
taken out of context,
you know,
the full extent.
I mean it was a joke and he was also
talking about his wife and because he met
his wife in the lab and,
and he was also making
himself to be for his,
it was a very self deprecating,
you didn't know the extent of it.
I did read some sort of
re reassessment of that.
Yep.
Dawkins printed the,
uh,
a full version of what he said
and it's very different also.
Everyone is laughing.
I read the full version.
Yeah.
Um,
but so it's like,
so this is actually a
perfect example because,
so if he was joking,
right.
So his intentions are totally good.
Is it possible that it's still
not helpful to make that,
that kind of a statement?
That's,
I think that's what
people are talking about,
right?
Uh,
when,
if,
if on one hand there's a lot of interest
trying to increase the number of women
in science and technology,
is it possible that somebody would hear
that and still be kind of demotivated by
it or kind of have that sink in?
So I think people are,
when they're,
when we're discussing these things,
uh,
I,
you don't have to police
other people's language,
but I think it's,
I still think it's useful to
say that might not be helpful.
Yeah.
The,
there's a,
an article on the leak transcript,
uh,
the leak transcript.
W w what happened was the
people that saw it thought it,
like,
at least some of them
thought was funny and,
but there were aspects of what he
said that we're probably Clum busy,
right.
Swanky or,
you know,
he was trying to be funny and he's
really just sort of an odd guy who's a
scientist.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
people decided that this
is an awesome target.
Like,
let's go after it.
Right.
And to make an example,
which happens on the UN,
I mean,
the whole people get
shamed on the Internet.
Now that's,
that's what happens.
Um,
I mean my,
you know,
I don't have any expertise in this area,
so it's probably not,
you know,
worth me know
bound.
The official quote he says is strange
as such a chauvinist monitor like me,
has it been asked to
speak to women scientist?
Let me tell you about
my trouble with girls.
His trouble with girls,
three things happen when
they were in the lab.
You Fall in love with them,
they fall in love with you
and when you criticize them,
they cry.
Perhaps we should make separate
labs for boys and girls now.
Seriously,
I'm impressed with the economic
development of a second.
This was before
not fair.
Of course he,
it was,
it was him joking.
Yeah.
But he's definitely,
he's joking,
playing on stereotypes that girls
cry and girls can't handle criticism.
I mean,
I'm just saying,
yeah,
I,
I'm not gonna say that I
think is totally fine to say,
hey,
when you say these things,
it might result in some girl thinking,
wait,
maybe I'm not going to be
a good scientist because,
because people say that girls aren't
good in the lab or whatever it is.
I wouldn't say it.
That's yeah,
I try to be,
I tried to be,
you know,
even when we say things like
about people who play games a lot,
you know,
um,
oh,
they're wasting their lives.
You know,
why don't you go out
and do something real?
Um,
I don't think that's useful to say either.
I think that that's actually,
uh,
can be really damaging identity.
Generalize,
you know,
men,
yes.
And women do that and girls aren't
good at being in the lab and it's,
it's,
it's damaging.
And I think now he understands that
a joke like that as innocent as a,
he might have intended it to be when
you're reading it in a text form,
especially in you taking
some of it out of context,
it can be,
it can be a offensive,
it can be hurtful for someone
who's considering like how
many girls were reading
that they were considering a
possible career in science.
One,
I don't have to with
fucking people like this.
Like I don't want to,
I'm not gonna cry in your lab,
asshole.
I just want to do work.
I want to be a scientist.
Yeah.
So we don't need to like police
people to have this conversation.
Right.
You know?
So
what does that sort of expose
in some ways it exposes a,
yeah.
Prevalent attitudes,
um,
that this guy who is this esteemed Nobel
winning scientist has this attitude,
you know,
that he thinks it's funny to joke
around about it and they're like,
even if he's not a sexist or a bad guy,
him making this joke about himself
being some chauvinist monster and it's
become,
one of the things is because his wife
is a prominent feminist and so he jokes
around about him being
a chauvinist monster.
Yeah.
You know?
Well that makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
it's all out of context and it's all also,
you're dealing with a guy who's,
who's real focus is,
is research,
not social interaction.
Right.
He's not like a nuanced speaker is not
a guy who is a carefully considered a
speaker who gets on stage and thinks
about everything and the impact of all,
I mean,
he,
like we were talking about like the
awkward interaction that people might have
in college.
Well,
this guy's awkward interaction is
him being forced to write a speech.
Like if he did this a bunch of times,
he'd probably get really way better at it.
And you have,
you sat down with him alone in,
you guys were just talking
over a glass of wine.
Maybe you'd understand how
his brain works better.
Yeah,
maybe I would have spoke.
Yeah.
If,
if something offends you,
it's more useful to have a conversation
about it then to just start.
Yeah.
But it's fun to blog and shit.
All of this guy is this guy,
he's old and he's white
and he's famous or so.
Well write a book about the neurochemistry
of outrage and because it's,
it's its own high,
you know,
it's recreational,
recreational outrage.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
A real thing.
Right?
Yeah.
And I think that that's what's going on
in colleges and that people are finding
when you're in college,
it's like when you were talking about
the addiction that people have to video
games.
And then one of the things that sort of
stimulates that addiction is if you're
trying to avoid things
in your regular lottery.
Okay.
Well,
if you're in college,
the,
the overwhelming anxiety of being a
young person who has gone from being,
living with their parents,
going to high school,
now you're in college and you were just
a couple of years away from the cliff of
real world,
like you're fucking sliding towards
it and you're trying to define it and
redefine it and change it
and establish yourself.
And then along the way comes
things that you can be angry at.
Well,
you will point your fucking fury.
There are really unmeasured are unbalanced
fury at those things where it doesn't
necessarily make sense,
but it makes sense to you because what
you're really doing is you're avoiding
the adjuncts have social anxiety of,
of,
of uh,
sexual rejection and all the,
all the shit that makes a
person feel weird things.
And you channel that
towards micro aggressions.
Are you that towards someone treat,
you know,
deciding to address you with
a male or a female pronoun.
You know,
there's like,
there's a lot of weirdness
to being a person and that,
that,
but you know,
the last thing I want to
say about this is part,
it is,
I think people are just trying
to make new roles for the game.
Right.
You know,
and,
and when you're trying to change the
rules of a game that is really upsetting.
If you're in the middle of the game,
you're playing a game and stuff is like,
ah,
wait,
totally,
can't do that now.
She,
we've always been here and she,
yeah,
yeah.
It's like,
oh,
you're playing soccer.
You can't kick the ball
anymore with your feet.
Right.
And you're in the middle of the game.
Right,
right.
Right.
So,
but it doesn't mean as
a game designer was say,
it doesn't mean that there isn't a
better game that actually could have
different rules,
but it's really upsetting to be in the
middle of a game and have somebody say,
wait.
Right.
Those aren't the rules.
So,
you know,
maybe we should,
maybe we should.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't know how to do
it better because I mean,
look,
I'm a progressive person and I'm glad
that things are changing in society in
lots of ways,
you know,
then I'm excited about
like,
what makes you happy?
What do you,
what do you think is good about the
changes in society in a progressive?
Well,
I'm,
I'm really glad that we
have marriage equality now.
I'm really excited about that.
I'm glad that,
um,
I mean paternity and maternity leave,
you know,
becoming more people having
longer maternity leave and
the same length paternity
leave for dads as a new parent.
I,
you know,
really excited to see
companies doing that.
Um,
and I like,
I like,
you know,
uh,
I like that we're starting to
talk about income inequality.
I mean optimistic that there will
be changes in that direction.
And I think that,
uh,
I think the black lives matter
is hugely important movement.
I think so.
I think there's a lot of conversations
going on right now where people are angry
or have struggled or feel like
they've been playing a rigged game.
And,
uh,
so it's not as long going to be pleasant
and not all the tactics are going to be
effective or good either.
But,
uh,
the general attitude is definitely
moving in a more progressive direction.
I think so.
And somebody
who has been,
you know,
I've,
I've had Twitter,
you know,
hordes yelling at me because they thought
that I was breaking one of the new
rules of how we're supposed to,
like what did people yell at?
You know,
one of the big instance I had was,
uh,
about,
my recommendations for
playing tetris after a trauma.
So there've been multiple randomized
control studies now out of Oxford
University showing that if you play tetris
within 24 hours of a traumatic event,
it will reduce the flashbacks.
You have the severity of flashbacks and
other PTSD symptoms because it occupies
your brain and prevents your
brain from kind of locking in and,
and obsessive compulsive
way on the trauma.
Right?
So this is,
I think this is incredibly important
advice that everyone should know.
Kind of like drop and roll.
You know,
if you catch on fire,
you know what to do.
Everybody should have tetris on their
phone and have it available to them.
If,
if,
because I know having suffered
flashbacks from my own head injury,
how,
I mean I would have nightmares and beat
of which I was hitting my head and I
would feel it as if a real,
and I'd wake up and I'd be convinced that
I had hit my head in the middle of the
night and was going to have
this experience all over again.
Um,
just nightmares constantly.
So I know how bad is
no one people to do it.
When I started tweeting about it,
people I got told that there needed to
be like trigger warnings on my tweets
because I was mentioning Ptsd and I
might make somebody think about like a
trauma that they experienced and um,
while they're trying to change the game.
Yeah.
So it's like I under,
I don't,
you know,
I've,
I've been on the other side of it where
people have said that I'm doing it
wrong,
but at the same time I recognize there
are people who are suffering or angry or
they have been at a disadvantage
because of the way the game is rigged.
And so I'm okay with there being like,
we're all going to be uncomfortable
for awhile as these things change.
And that's,
you know,
so you're uncomfortable with being
unjustly accused of being insensitive when
you're bringing out the
scientific research that
shows that a game can help you
with trauma.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I think I've,
I'm,
I'm going to keep doing it,
you know,
but I understand that the people who
say it are hurting the people who,
who are telling me that
I'm triggering them.
So irrational.
I think that all irrational behavior like
that should either be ignored or shit
on.
I really do.
I just think it's dangerous.
I think it's dangerous
when it gets pointed out.
Like your,
your science,
you're pointing out the scientific
aspects of a very specific activity that's
very good for trauma.
And they're saying that you
shouldn't talk about this now.
That's nonsense.
Well,
that's why I still talk about it.
Right.
But I don't have to get
into a fight with them.
Yeah.
No,
you certainly don't.
You should ignore them.
Right.
Or Shit on them,
depending on how you feel.
Yeah.
But I think that there's,
there's definitely a,
I like how we're defining life as like a
giant game or is equal to a giant game.
Cause I think that that's what's
going on also with the reaction,
the negative reaction
to progressive thinking.
Now like a,
I was tweeting something about,
um,
this woman in,
uh,
Kentucky that was trying to stop people
from getting gay marriage licenses.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I really,
I took a few days where I wasn't paying
attention to Twitter that much and I
didn't know that there was this
giant movement supporting this woman.
And I went to Mike Huckabee's fucking
Twitter page and saw that this crazy old
asshole was like saying that
there's a war against Christians.
And that like Hashtag religious liberty
and so it was like that doesn't have a
religious liberty doesn't mean you
enforce your religion on other people.
Right.
But that's so crazy.
Yeah and there was so much blow back.
I got so many people tweeting at me
angrily tweeting at me for saying like,
and I tweeted something about Ted Cruz
about how ridiculous his views are on
marriage and like that he's probably gay
and I'm like if you've listened to the
way that guy talks,
he's super feminine.
Like there's like how many times we
have to see this where these men,
right?
Because I have a bit that I used to do
my act that there's two types of people
that hate gay marriage.
It's either you're really dumb or
you're secretly worried the decks are
delicious.
Those are the people.
And like this guy is like
there's something going on here.
Why does he care so much about
two people that are in love that,
but watching the people that are angry
that the game is being redefined and
there was all this,
it was all this Christian
stuff that was attached to it.
Like,
well,
guess what?
Guess what else it says not to do in
the Bible it says not to get divorced.
Like this lady,
the same lady has been
divorced three times.
She's on her fourth marriage.
Guess what else it says you're
not supposed to have tattoos.
Okay.
Those people were tattooed
with religious symbols on them.
You've got a cross on your
arm and you tattooed it.
She fucking,
you gotta read the whole book like crazy.
Like the things that they choose and it,
what it is,
is they trying to,
they're trying to define the
world that they're playing in.
Yeah.
We're trying to define right.
And I think it's important because
even though I might disagree,
I mean I,
I vehemently disagree with people whose
perspective seem to be fueled by hate.
But I think it's important to still
try to have the empathy or the,
the mental insight to understand
why does this make them feel so bad?
I think what you just said,
and you have the feeling that you
thought you understood the rules.
I mean religion is a set of roles.
You thought you understood it.
You're,
you're playing the game right.
You're doing it right.
Um,
and it is,
it is psychologically distressing to have
somebody else tell you were playing a
different game.
Yeah.
You know,
your game sucks.
Um,
and you're not going to
go to play it anymore.
Uh,
I,
I try to understand where those feelings
are coming from because if you're going
to change people's minds,
you know,
you have to,
I think you have to acknowledge
that they are in a real,
they are really in distress about this,
you know,
then I doing this just to be jerks.
I mean they,
this is why change is fall to them.
Well,
why are they in distress about something
that doesn't directly affect them?
But it's because of what you just said.
Because it is,
it is,
it feels,
it's,
they have committed to a framework,
a set of roles and,
and,
and put,
that's it.
Once you're in it,
you're in it and,
and you know,
when you're playing a game,
you always try to stop the cheaters and
you protect the boundaries of the game.
That's,
that's a mindset you get
into and they're just,
they think they're just doing it.
What kind of country that was
established by Christian values.
Yes.
The fucking games locked.
Yeah.
Okay.
You can't change the rules.
That's,
it really does seem like we've,
we've kind of touched on something here.
Yeah.
This is a,
this has been a really
good one for me was the,
the,
the overall looking at the,
the whole existence as instead
of defining it by the word game,
but looking at it with almost the same
sort of a attitude or approach that you
would look at a game is
a very beneficial good.
It's worked for me.
You can,
your eyes get big like saucers.
Like you,
like you did it,
you did it,
you scored,
you made it happen.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
also,
like the,
the,
the ebb and flow of culture,
like the things that are
seemed to definitely,
even,
even though I resist like this nonsense
about microaggressions and trigger
warnings and stuff like that,
I'm very happy that things are moving
in the direction of acceptance.
Yeah.
Very happy that,
you know,
like you can be whatever
the fuck you want.
You just saw you're a woman today.
Go ahead.
As long as you don't hurt anybody,
who cares?
This guy wants to wear
dresses and you want,
he wants you to call him Jane now.
Fine.
Okay.
You know,
these two guys want to
get married to each other.
Terrific.
You know,
these two people want to stop
wearing makeup and they want to,
what do you give a shit?
Who Cares?
Or they want to dye their hair blue.
That's fine too.
Like eventually we'll all figure out
that we are all just unique individuals
that are a part of giant,
this gigantic super organism and the
most conducive way or the most harmonic
way,
harmonious way for us to interact with
each other is to fuck with each other's
path.
The least whatever path you're
on your way in your game,
as long as it doesn't
negatively affect people.
As long as you're not
a destroyer out there,
your path is to burn down
to the people's houses.
Your path is to steal.
Your path has to to hurt people.
As long as that's not going on.
Why care and,
and then ultimately once
that is established,
I think then we will focus on,
okay,
well what are our rear real
issues are real issues?
Aren't gay people getting
married to each other?
A real issues are the people that actually
are burning houses down the people
that are stealing.
Yeah.
Like these are the real
issues that people have.
People that are not micro aggressions,
but actual aggressions.
People that are actually committing
crimes against each other and why are they
doing that?
Well,
what is wrong with their game?
What happened to them?
Like what,
what series of events have placed
them in this sort of position?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Because it's not,
I mean,
people don't get into that in a vacuum.
No.
I think that's also something you
realized once you have children.
Yeah.
Like you have now.
And as a father,
one of the things has changed radically
in my life is seeing people now.
Like when I meet people,
I see them as babies that have grown up.
Like I don't see them as
being in a static state.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's,
it's very strange,
like even assholes that,
I mean,
I'd look at them and even go,
that guy's a fucking asshole.
I think of them as like,
what happened to that person?
But you know,
that's like a,
that's I practice Zen Buddhism and
that's like one of the big Buddhist
meditations is to
picture people as babies.
Yeah.
When you feel hate for somebody,
try to visualize them all the way down
to throw little baby self and picture
what they look like as a baby and to
think about who they were when they were
that baby before all of
life happened to them,
to make them into somebody
that has now triggered these,
you know,
hate feelings of anger
in the womb.
You know,
I was talking to Michael Irvin famous
pro football player who's talking to me
about kids that grow up
in horrible environments,
dangerous volatile environments where
the mother has all this cortisol in her
brain while the child in the womb and
that the kid literally grows up like with
a short temper.
Yeah.
They literally,
they're developed out of the womb,
like constantly worried
about stress and danger.
Yeah.
Hypervigilant.
All of that.
I've had feral cats.
I had a cat that was feral
at her raised and uh,
he was fucking terrified of everything
from the time he was a baby and a,
I've locked myself in a room with them
when he was a kitten because there's the
only way like bond with him.
I stayed with him for like three,
I just put a bunch of books in the room
and cat food and the litter box and be
like,
you and me,
dude,
we're hanging out and
want to come near him.
And he'd be like,
he just jumped on the walls and like
you'd never seen anything like a feral
kitten.
I mean he was really little
to just a couple months old.
And uh,
when,
uh,
when I would get to them and pick them up.
Right.
He was talking [inaudible]
like finally somebody loves me.
Like,
but then when you put them down,
like the same cat would just be,
yeah,
because his brain was programmed
from the time he was a little baby.
Yeah.
And there was not a lot he could do.
I couldn't say that cat's ass asshole.
Well,
no,
that fucking cat was born
under an apartment building,
you know,
and his mom was like running away
from traffic and trying to eat rats or
whatever the fuck they could kill.
Yeah.
Well,
I think this is one of the reasons why
game thinking is so powerful because you,
this is zoom out and see the
bigger structure that it's,
it's,
there's always a bigger game and more
pieces in play and you're getting other
people's,
you know,
strategies or actions or,
or the rules,
you know,
um,
and being able to zoom out
and see that makes you feel,
I think will you have more perspective,
more wisdom and maybe more
compassion for other people.
That's awesome.
Why people like to rightly so criticized,
very narrow minded,
small town thinking.
Yeah.
Small little environments,
insulated environments that are very,
you know,
very critic criticizing or very,
just to,
just to have their,
their way set and they don't have a wide
variety of experiences they can draw
upon or they don't have a broad
nuanced view of the board that there,
yeah.
Playing on.
Yeah.
So this is like,
this is giving me a lot of
what a food for thought about.
I mean,
the links between social
change and gainful thinking.
Yeah.
There's something there.
I think also as time is going on and uh,
this is one thing,
the,
the positive aspects of social media
and of the Internet itself is that we're
getting more and more information instead
of just accepting these preconceived
notions that we have about
different groups of people.
Now we're being to so much data,
it's just inadvertently or a inarguably
changing the way we view those groups
and that you are forced to like when you
see like this black lives matter thing,
you see all these peaceful protests
where these people are talking eloquently
speaking and showing video after video,
police brutality.
And then I've had,
I had a cop on Michael Wood who was a
Baltimore retired Baltimore police officer
that talked about,
very openly talked about
the institutionalized racism
and about how they had
found a papers from the 1970s that we're
describing how to behave in certain
environments that were exactly
the same as what's going on now.
He's like,
this is a fucking system.
This is the,
I don't think that attitude
existed just a few years ago.
People are looking at all
that data now and they go,
it's slowly coming around and
even the hard liners are dropping.
You know,
if they were at a 10 now
they're at an a or a seven,
well I fucking kid,
you need to get all caught
a school or something.
You know,
it's like everyone is sort of slowly
recognizing the pieces that are in play.
It's a lot more complicated
then we want to,
you know,
just narrowly sort of
define them and these,
these really simplistic
terms where it's not simple.
There's a series of interactions that
are going on all over the globe are human
beings are trying to find their way.
And they're also realizing somewhere
along the line that their parents weren't
these all knowing creatures.
Neither were their parents,
neither were the President
Roosevelt or fucking Abe Lincoln.
They were all people that were
trying to find their way as well.
And this is a group effort.
It's a group effort that's still going
on and it's not even remotely done.
It's not even close.
Yeah.
So it's okay.
So instead of seeing the bigger picture,
we will see the bigger
game and that will be,
that will guide us.
Yes.
Bringing all right back to super better.
All right.
You got to get out of here.
You're going to catch a flight.
So thank you very much.
Um,
I'll put your video up on
Twitter and we'll put your,
the link to your book,
which is available right now.
Right?
Uh,
well it drops next Tuesday,
but you can buy it now.
Oh,
you buy it now,
but you can get it next Tuesday.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
thank you so much.
Really,
really appreciate it.
All right,
and uh,
what's your Twitter address
again?
It's an avant game.
Ava and t.
T a m Emmy.
You can just search
for my name Jane Games.
It'll come up.
All right.
Beautiful.
Thank you so much.
Awesome time.
Okay.
Much.